İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar, 7 Ağustos 2024 çarşamba günü saat 19.31 12. ders günümüz dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen sevgili arkadaşlar.
Kaldığımız yere hemen geri dönüyoruz copy assignment function özel sınıfların özel fonksiyonlarından bir başkası son kez sayalım mı özelliğe fonksiyonları evet default constructor, destructor, copy constructor, move constructor, copy assignment, move assignment.
Evet, constructorları ve default constructor'ı gördük, destructor'ı gördük, evet pazartesi günkü dersimizde copy constructor üstünde durduk, copy constructor'ın ne olduğunu, ne işe yaradığını, ne zaman bizim tanımlamamız gerektiğini konuştuk ve kopyalayan atama operatör fonksiyonuna yani copy assignment function'a geldik.
Arkadaşlar, hatta sınıfımız için, örnek sınıfımız için bir kopyalayan atama operatör fonksiyonu, copy assignment function yazdık.
Tipik olarak kaynak kullanan böyle sınıflar, eğer derleyiciye bırakmazlarsa ki derleyiciye bıraksalar felaket olurdu.
Ne yapıyorlar?
Önce kendi kaynağını geri veriyor, sonra deep copy yapıyor.
Arkadaşlar, öylediğimi yani atama operatör fonksiyonuyla kopyalayan atama operatör fonksiyonuyla copy constructor'ın ortak kodu deyip copy diyebiliriz.
Ama atama operatör fonksiyonu bir constructor değil, derleyicinin nasıl bir fonksiyon yazdığını konuştuk.
Derleyicinin yazdığı fonksiyon işimizi görmediğinde biz fonksiyonu implemente ediyoruz.
Derleyicinin yazdığı fonksiyonun işimizi görüyorsa rule of zero deyip arkadaşlar biz derleyiciye bırakıyoruz özel üye fonksiyonların yazımını.
En son şöyle bir şey eklemiştik atama operatör fonksiyonuna.
Dedik ki self assignment'a da bir önlem alması gerekiyor.
Self assignment ne demek?
Self assignment şunu isterseniz jpp dosyasına bir kopyalayalım, tekrar aynı örnek üstünde çalışalım.
Nesnenin kendine atanması yani atama operatörünün sol operandı da aslında burada da varmış sanıyorum sağ operandı da yine aynı nesne.
Eğer bu durumda önlem almazsak ki işte alınan tipik önlem bu, eğer self assignment söz konusu değilse fonksiyon hiçbir şey yapmayacak.
İngilizcesiyle noop olacak.
Bunu da atama operatörünün sol operandının sağ operandıyla aynı nesne olup olmadığını sınamak için diz pointer'ının değeri olan adresin parametre referansın bağlandığı nesnenin adresine ki o atama operatörünün sağ operanda olan nesne eşitliğini sınıyoruz.
Bu arada kalıtımla ilgili geçen bir arkadaşım yorum yapmıştı Cengiz Han.
Onu tabi kalıtım konusunda göreceğiz.
Arkadaşımın yaptığı yorum doğru ama şu anda ona değinmeyeceğim.
Tipik olarak bu şekilde yazılıyor.
Şimdi burada birkaç tane anahtar nokta arkadaşlar.
Bir, bu fonksiyonlar bizim tarafımızdan ne zaman yazılması gerekiyor bunu konuştuk.
Yani sınıfınızın elemanları handle ya da handle'lar değilse sınıfınızın elemanları yine aynak kontrolünü kendisi gerçekleştiren sınıflarsa
yani eleman olan nesnelerin zaten copy constructor'ı, efendim copy assignment'ı ve birazdan görmeye başlayacağımız move constructor, move assignment
bunlar zaten sınıf tarafından yazılmışsa derleyiciye bırakmamızda bir sakınca yok.
Çünkü derleyici kendi yazdığı copy constructor'da sınıfın elemanlarını copy construct ediyor.
Bu durumda elemanların copy construct'ları çağrılacak.
Yani örneğin en çok kullanılan sınıflar oldukları için örneği şimdilik bunlardan veriyorum.
Stud string, stud vector gibi ya da stud map gibi nesneler arkadaşlar sınıfın elemanı olan nesneler
zaten copy construct'ları, copy assignment'ları implemente edilmiş uygun şekilde kaynak yönetimini yapan deep copy işlemini kendileri gerçekleştiriyorlar.
Dolayısıyla onlara herhangi bir şekilde müdahale etmemize gerek yok.
Arkadaşlar, copy assignment'la ilgili şöyle bir şey de söyledim.
Bunu bir not düşelim ileride tekrar buraya dönmek üzere.
Dedim ki bir de copy assignment function'ın idiomatik başka bir şekilde bir yazım biçimi var.
Bu yazım biçimine ilişkin idioma, duyan var mı demiştim, sormuştum.
Hatta yine sorayım.
Duyan var mı, bilen var mı?
Çok da sık kullanıyor endüstride.
Arkadaşlar, copy swap idiom deniyor.
Yani copy swap idiom'ı kullanıyorsanız,
adama operatör fonksiyonu, copy assignment'ı böyle yazmıyorsunuz.
Ama şimdi oraya girmek istemiyorum.
Nasıl yazıyoruz ve neden öyle yazıyoruz?
Çünkü copy swap idiom'un kullanılmasının birinci nedeni,
strong exception garanti sağlamak.
Ama biz şimdi exception handling'i hiç görmedik.
Dolayısıyla exception handling nedir bilen arkadaşlarım vardır.
Ama kursun gidişatı için de henüz görmedik.
Oradaki garantiler ne anlama geliyor?
Basic exception garanti, strong exception garanti,
arkadaşlar no throw garanti gibi.
Onlarla ilgili olduğunu söyleyebiliriz.
Copy swap idiom'unu.
Yine ortak koddan bahsetmiştim.
Destructor kaynağı geri veriyor böyle sınıflarda.
Ben böyle sınıflara biraz kendi uydurduğum terim ama
rayi sınıfları diyorum.
Destructor kaynağı, kaynakları geri veriyor.
Onu release resources diye isimlendirebiliriz bu işlemi.
Copy constructor deep copy yapıyor.
Atama operatör fonksiyonu, copy assignment,
hem release resources hem deep copy yapıyor.
Dolayısıyla bir başka ileride tercih edebileceğimiz çözüm
bu ortak kodları belki uygun şekilde isimlendirilmiş
başka fonksiyonlara yüklemek,
o fonksiyonların destructor, copy constructor ve copy assignment için
o fonksiyonların çağrılmasını sağlamak.
Evet, şimdi arkadaşlar eğer modern C++'da olmasaydık,
onun biraz öncesinde olsaydık,
şöyle meşhur popüler bir terim vardı.
Büyük üçlü, big three.
Büyük üçlü aslında şuna deniyordu.
Şu üç fonksiyon, biri destructor,
bir yeri copy constructor,
bir yeri assignment operator function.
Eskiden zaten iki tane assignment function yoktu,
bir tane vardı.
Ama şimdi orada ikinci bir assignment fonksiyonu geldi,
move assignment.
Birazdan onu göreceğiz.
Şöyle deniyordu,
eğer bu fonksiyonlardan birini,
özellikle de destructor'ı,
yazımını derleyiciye bırakmak yerine,
yazımını kendiniz yapmak zorunda hissediyorsanız,
o zaman diğer iki fonksiyonu da implemente etmelisiniz.
Çünkü destructor'ı yazma nedeni tipik olarak bir kaynağın geri verilmesi,
bu durumda copy constructor ve assignment operator function derleyici tarafından yazılırsa,
onların kodu uygun, düşmeyecek.
Bu yüzden bunlardan birinin yazılması durumunda,
eğer çok çok çok çok sıra dışı bir durum söz konusu değilse,
diğer ikisinin de yine programcı tarafından tanımlanması gerekiyor.
Buna işaret etmek için big tree terimi,
popüler bir terim standartın şüphesiz kullandığı bir terim değil,
kullanılıyordu.
Peki şimdi neden kullanılmıyor?
Hemen bir görüş alalım, tahmin alalım.
Madem bu kadar önemli bir kural,
şimdi neden kullanılmıyor?
Çünkü işin içine,
bravo Fatih Akgül,
bir de muğlar girdi,
taşıma semanti eklendi.
O zaman belki big tree yerine big five demekte fayda var.
Yani işin içine bizim de neleri katmamız gerekecek,
muğ konstruktör ile muğ assignment'ı birlikte katmamız gerekecek.
Arkadaşlar,
muğ semantiği basit gibi görünse de,
aslında bir hayli karmaşık.
yani özünde basit.
Fakat bilmeniz gereken,
gerçekten çok fazla nokta var.
Bu taşıma semantiğini öğrenirken.
Ben,
taşıma semantiğini,
ileri C++ kursunda,
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam,
böyle 20-30 saatlik bir konu,
olarak ele alıyorum.
bunun için de,
taşıma semantiğinin,
jenerik kodlarda,
yani türden bağımsız yazılan kodlarda,
kullanılması,
ve yine bununla ilişkili olarak,
perfect wording dediğimiz,
mekanizma,
daha çok yine,
jenerik programlama paradigmasıyla ilgili.
Hocam,
ileri C++ kursu ne zaman olacak?
Bir aksilik olmazsa,
Kasım gibi kesin açılacak.
Kasım ya da,
Aralık.
Yani,
bu kurs,
şöyle söyleyelim ya da,
bu kursun bitiminden sonra açılacak ki,
bekleyen bazı arkadaşlarım var,
bu kurstan da belki katılmak isteyen olursa,
o zaman,
yeterli öğrenci sayısına ulaşıyoruz.
İleri C++'a talep,
bu ne diyelim,
ileri olmayan,
normal C++'a olan talepten,
daha az şüphesiz.
Çünkü,
biraz zor da bir kurs konular,
biraz daha zor,
karmaşık,
herkes almak istemiyor.
Ya da belki bu kadarını,
yeterli buldukları için.
Şimdi,
taşıma semantiğine geçmeden önce,
bir noktayı tekrar,
vurgulamak istiyorum.
Function overloading ile ilgili.
Çünkü,
taşıma semantiği,
şimdi,
üstünden tekrar geçeceğimiz,
function overloading'in,
özel bir durumuyla,
son derece ilgili.
Değerli arkadaşlar,
izleyin.
Buraya geri döneceğim.
Ya da,
şöyle kahvetmeyelim,
geri döneceğiz derken.
Evet.
Ne olur,
ne olmaz,
bir kere daha kopyalayalım.
Okey.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
şu overloading yapısını,
tekrar bir,
hatırlamanızı istiyorum.
Bir sınıfımız var.
Diyelim ki,
class,
net,
net.
Bir fonksiyonumuz var.
Word,
u.
Parametresi,
const,
net,
red.
Bir fonksiyonumuz daha var.
Parametresi,
net,
ref,
ref.
Şimdi bu,
çok sık karşımıza çıkan bir,
overloading.
Bu arada,
yanlış anlamı olmasın.
Buraya örneğin,
en az iki overload daha koyabilirim.
Arkadaşlar,
biri şöyle olabilir.
İzleyin.
Kanslı olmayan,
necrif.
Hatta,
hatta,
kullanımı,
neredeyse hiç olmayan,
semantik karşılığı,
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam,
sadece,
stud optional sınıfında olan,
şu bile olabilir.
Yani,
bunun bile var olduğunu,
bazen gerekli olabileceğini düşünebilirsiniz.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Bakın bakın,
burada kaç tane overload var?
Tam tamına,
dört tane overload var.
Şöyle,
sırasıyla kaveh,
bakalım,
on birinci satırdan başlayalım.
Şunu bir diyelim,
bu,
const olmayan,
lvalue ref.
Const lvalue ref,
rvalue ref,
arkadaşlar,
ve const rvalue ref.
Tekrar söylüyorum,
dördüncüsü,
tipik olarak,
bir işe yaramıyor.
Semantik,
karşılığı hiç olamaz demiyorum,
ama çok nadir.
Ama yine de bir overload.
Süper.
Arkadaşlar,
fakat daha çok,
üretimde karşımıza çıkacak,
ya da kullanacağımız,
kütüphanelerde karşımıza çıkacak,
şu ikisi,
diğer ikisi,
çoğunlukla,
bunlarla birlikte olmayacak.
O zaman buna bir diyelim,
buna iki diyelim.
Arkadaşlar,
böyle bir overloadla neyi sağlıyoruz?
Son derece basit.
Lvalue ve rvalue sınıf nesneleri için,
farklı implementasyonlar sunuluyor.
11. satırdaki fonksiyon diyor ki,
lvalue neç argümanları bana gelsin.
12. satırdaki fonksiyon diyor ki,
rvalue olan argümanlar bana gelsin.
şimdi,
sadece beni izleyin.
Diyelim ki,
burada bir lvalue ifade var.
My neç.
neç.
Hemen altına da,
hemen altına da,
rvalue olan bir neç ifadesi yazalım.
Henüz görmedik ama yakın göreceğiz.
Arkadaşlar,
bu şekilde oluşturulan nesnelere,
ilerleyen saatlerde,
temporary objects diyeceğiz.
Bakın,
bu çok önemli bir konu.
Önce terimi yazalım.
Temporary objects.
Necati bunu ayrı bir başlık altında mı inceleyeceğiz?
Kesinlikle.
Ya neden böyle bir sentaks var?
Ne işe yarıyor?
Fakat şimdilik,
temporary objects derken,
kastedilen ifadelerin,
tipik olarak,
bir sınıf türünden nesne anlamına geldiği bir,
fakat ortada,
o nesnenin isminin olmadığı ifadeler.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın burada bir değişkenin ismi var.
Fakat burada bir değişkenin ismi yok.
Sınıfın ismi var sadece.
Ama bu da,
nec türünden bir nesne,
bu da nec türünden bir nesne.
Aradaki,
ikinci önemli fark,
bir ismin olması ya da olmamasının yanında,
bu ifadelerin value kategorilerinin farklı olması.
şüphesiz bir ismin söz konusu olduğu ifadeler,
l-value expression,
ama ismin olmadığı ifadeler,
r-value expression.
Ve burada tabi r-value expression'ın combined value kategori olduğunu,
yani,
hem,
p-r-value expression olan primary value kategorinin,
hem de,
arkadaşlar,
x-value olan primary value kategorisinin,
birleşim kümesi olduğunu,
r-value kategorisinin,
hatırlayalım.
Dolayısıyla ben birinci değer kategorisinden bahsediyor olsaydım,
buna p-r-value diyecektim.
Arkadaşlar,
ama bakın,
yine gün içinde,
geri döneceğimiz bir derste bahsetmiştik.
İsmi,
move olan fonksiyona,
argüman olarak,
bir l-value expression verirseniz,
bu const expr function,
ismi move olan fonksiyon,
ne yapıyor?
Kötü isimlendirildiğinden daha önce bahsetmiştim,
bir İngilizcesiyle misnomer.
Ne yapıyor?
Move falan yapmıyor.
Hatta Scott Meyers'ın ünlü bir gümlesi var,
çok sık atıfta bulunulan,
move doesn't move.
Yani stud move doesn't move.
Move yapmıyor.
Ne yapıyor?
Move cast yapıyor.
Stud move fonksiyonu,
ileride nasıl implement edildiğini de göstereceğim arkadaşlar.
Sadece ne yapıyor?
L-value alırsa,
onu r-value'ya dönüştürüyor.
r-value'yu,
yine r-value olarak veriyor.
Dolayısıyla,
move fonksiyonu,
l-value'da gelse,
r-value'da gelse,
kendisine argüman olarak,
r-value kategorisinde bir ifade oluşturuyor.
Aslında,
bu ileride yine detaylı göreceğimiz move fonksiyonu yerine,
pekala,
şunu da yazabilirsiniz.
Static cast,
arkadaşlar,
nec,
refref,
efendim,
nezne.
Yani ben pekala,
move'u çağırmak yerine,
static cast operatörünü bu şekilde kullanıp,
move'un geri dönüş değeri yerine,
static cast operatörünün oluşturduğu ifadeyi kullanabilirim.
Arada gerçekten pratik olarak fark yok.
Fakat tabi,
stud move'u daha zengin kullanım olanağı veriyor.
Onu ileride göreceğiz.
Belki tek suçu,
stud move'un,
kötü isimlendirilmiş olması.
Ve öğrenenlerin,
işini biraz zorlaştırması.
Çünkü,
bunu gören,
taşımayı,
sanki bu fonksiyonun yaptığını zannediyor.
Taşımaya gelmedik.
Ama neden bahsediyorum?
Bakın şimdi,
r-value expression olan,
sınıf nesnesi oluşturan birkaç tane ifade var.
Biri,
yine az önce söylediğim gibi,
önümüzdeki derslerden birinin alt başlığı olacak,
temporary object oluşturma ifadeleri.
İkincisi,
arkadaşlar,
birkaç tanesini söyleyelim.
İkincisi,
stud move fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrı ifadesi.
Üçüncüsü,
stud move yerine,
efendim,
sınıf türünden,
r-value reference türüne,
cast eden,
static cast operatörüyle ifadeler.
Fakat,
arada belki şöyle bir fark var.
Bu da r-value,
ama bunun primary value kategorisi,
x-value.
x-value ifadelerle ilgili,
çok fazla konuşmadık.
Ama sadece,
şimdilik,
bir ipucu vereyim.
en sık karşımıza çıkma ihtimali olan,
x-value kategorisindeki ifadeler,
geri dönüş değeri,
sağ taraf referansı olan,
fonksiyonlara yapılan,
çağrı ifadeleri.
yani örneğin,
bar gibi bir fonksiyon bu şekilde bildirilmişse,
arkadaşlar,
bar fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrı ifadesi,
value kategori olarak,
x-value.
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ama,
tabii ki,
aynı zamanda r-value.
Dolayısıyla,
bir daha tekrar edecek olursak,
move fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrı,
static cast operatörünün,
az önce söylediğim gibi kullanımı,
efendim,
geri dönüş değeri,
sağ taraf referansı olan bir fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrı,
ve,
geri dönüş değeri,
referansı olmayan,
doğrudan tür olan bir fonksiyona yapılan çağrı ifadeleri,
tipik r-value expression'lar.
Ama,
şimdi konuya geri dönmek istiyorum.
Bunları göreceğiz zaten.
Nereden başladık?
Böyle bir overload varsa,
arkadaşlar,
böyle bir overloadda,
l-value expression argüman,
birinci overloadun çağrılmasını sağlayacak,
function overload resolution'la,
sağ taraf değeri olan,
x-value'de olabilir,
pr-value'de olabilir,
bir argüman,
ikinci fonksiyonun çağrılması sonucunda olacak.
Burası kritik önemi,
önem taşıyor.
o zaman tekrar şimdi ben size soracak olursam,
nec, may nec,
soru bir,
bu, may nec,
hangisi çağrılır?
Cevap,
tabii ki bir.
Bravo,
arkadaşlar.
Soru iki,
oysa ben may nec'i bu şekilde argüman olarak kullanmak yerine,
ilerleyen saatlerde belki daha ayrıntılı göreceğimiz,
stud move fonksiyonla may nec'i argüman olarak gönderirsem,
ve argüman olarak bu ifadeyi kullanırsam,
bu artık bir r-value expression olduğu için iki çağrılacak değil mi?
Yine,
bakın bunların hepsine çok dikkat edin,
yine,
henüz detaylı görmesek de,
fonksiyona gönderdiğim argüman,
eğer bir temporary object ifadesiyse,
bu da p-r-value expression,
dolayısıyla r-value expression,
yine hangi fonksiyon çağrılacak?
Alihan,
Samet,
Kaan,
Kave,
tabii ki iki çağrılacak.
Evet,
ya da ya da ya da az önceki fonksiyona bakınız,
geri dönüş değeri nec olan bar fonksiyonu,
ya da geri dönüş değeri nec rep rep olan,
efendim,
baz fonksiyonu,
baz.
Şimdi,
bu'ya argüman olarak bar fonksiyonla yapılan çağrı ifadesini verirsem,
yine bir r-value expression argüman vermiş oluyorum.
Yine baz fonksiyonla yapılan çağrı ifadesini arkadaşlar argüman olarak verirsem,
yine r-value expression oluyor.
Muhammed Furkan Toptaş,
nec ref ref,
my nec ifadesi ile de,
C tipi şeklinde r-value expression yapabilir miyiz?
Biz yapabiliriz ama yapmayız, o ayrı.
Yapabiliriz.
yani aslında C tarzı tür dönüştürme operatörünün kullanımında,
genel olarak bir problem yok.
ama şimdi yapabilir miyiz başka?
asla yapmayalım.
Asla yapmayalım.
Yani her zaman eğer statikest operatörünü kullanmak ya da C++'ın genel olarak tür dönüştürme operatörlerini kullanmak çok istisnai sayılabilecek birkaç durumun dışında her zaman birinci tercihimiz.
Şimdi neden buraya girdiğimi anlatayım, çok dikkatli izliyorsunuz, o zaman şöyle yapalım, şu fonksiyonları çağıralım.
Bu, nec, bir soru soracağım çünkü çok önemli.
Bu, su, mu, my nec.
Tamam.
Şimdi beni takip etmeye devam edin.
21, özür dilerim, 22, 23, 24 ve 25. satırdaki fonksiyon çağrıları hangi fonksiyona bağlanacak?
Function overload resolution ile istisnansız hepsi arkadaşlar ikinci fonksiyona bağlanacak.
Şimdi soruyu anlamaya çalışın.
Hatta bir ipucu vermemek için önce soruyu sözel olarak sorayım.
İkinci overloadu silersem, sentaks hatası olur mu?
Bu kodda, görünüz, Rasul Mamadol, hayır.
Muhammed Furkan, hayır.
Muhammed Ateşoğlu, Oğuzhan Esin, hayır hayır.
Süper cevap, olmaz.
İsterseniz bakın, kodda tabii yanlışlıkla yazdım, başka bir öğe yoksa.
Bu legal.
Ama şimdi ikinci overloadu sildim.
Yine legal.
Çünkü const L value referans, R value'a da bağlanıyor, L value'a da bağlanıyor.
Doğru mu?
Kesinlikle R value'a da, L value'a da bağlanıyor.
Dolayısıyla sağ taraf, sol taraf değeriyle çağırmak zorunda değilim ki.
Evet.
Şimdi bu durum için ilerleyen saatlerde yine popüler bir terim kullanılıyor.
Arkadaşlar, fallback.
Duydunuz mu?
Yani bu tabii İngilizce'de genel bir terim ama burada fallback'i şu anlamda kullanacağım.
Ve siz de belki başka kitaplarda, yazılarda, makalelerde, videolarda kullanıldığını göreceksiniz.
Normalde hem L value referans, hem de const L value referans, hem de R value referans parametreli iki fonksiyon varsa, iki overload varsa, R value'ları R value referans parametreli, L value'ları L value referans parametreli, const L value referans parametreli oluyor.
Ama R value referans parametreli, overload olmadığında hepsini kim alıyor?
Arkadaşlar, L value referans parametreli oluyor.
Burayı anladık mı?
Yani sağ taraf referans parametreli den olsaydı o olacaktı ama o olmadığı için, Türkçeleştirelim biraz, nereye düşüyor?
Const Natch Ref, bu örnek için konuşuyorum, parametreli fonksiyona düşüyor.
Bunu şimdi bir köşeye yazın.
Buraya geri döneceğiz.
Şimdi gelelim arkadaşlar, move constructora ve move assignment'a.
Öyle durumlar var ki, aslında koda bakarak biz, aynı zamanda derleyici, bir sınıf nesnesinin artık kullanılma olanağının olmadığını, o nesneye kullanacak bir kodun söz konusu olmadığını derleyici anlayabiliyor.
Biz de koda bakarak anlayabiliyoruz arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi böyle bir durumda bir sınıf nesnesi varken, diyelim ki bizim string sınıfı gibi, onun değeriyle başka bir sınıf nesnesini hayata getirmek istediğimde,
şimdiye kadar, arkadaşlar buraya dikkat, yani modern C++'dan önce şimdiye kadar derken,
değerini kullanacağım, değerini alacağım sınıf nesnesinin hayatı bitecek olmasına karşın,
onu kullanacak hiçbir kodu olmayacak, onun hayatı bitecek olmasına karşın, onun kaynağını yine kopyalıyorduk birçok durumda.
Fakat, şimdi dilin nasıl bir olanağı, sentaks düzeyinde söz konusu oldu,
adeta şunu yapacağız, bakın bakın, sen sınıf nesnesi, seni kullanacak başka bir kod yok zaten,
senin hayatın bitecek, sen gidicisin Türkçe, bilmiyorum bu, siz de kullanıyor musunuz Resul bu sözü,
sen gidicisin, yani öbür dünyaya gideceksin, öleceksin, destroy olacaksın,
o zaman ben neden senin kaynağını kopyalıyım, ben senin kaynağını edineyim, kaynağa devralıyım, kaynağa çalayım.
Burada gerçekten İngilizce'de kullanılan, arkadaşlar fiil, steal, to steal the resource.
Kaynağını çalıyorum, arkadaşlar bakın şimdi,
geçen halen duruyor mu, kötü kötü çizimler yapmıştım ama,
duruyor çizimlerden biri.
Şimdi kafanızda canlandırmaya çalışın, ne demek istediğimi anlamaya çalışın.
Şunları da sileyim, sadece bir tanesi kalsın.
Evet, şimdi diyelim ki böyle bir string sınıfı türünden nesnemiz var, bizim yazdığımız string sınıfından bahsediyorum.
Fakat biz biliyoruz ki, böyle ismi de olmak zorunda değil, sınıf nesnesinin hayatı bitecek.
Hayatı biterken, bunun için destraktör çağrılacak.
Destraktör da, hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi,
dynamikle, allocated, dinamik olarak edinilmiş,
bu bellek bloğunu geri verecek.
Ama şimdi, ben bu sınıf nesnesinin değeriyle başka bir sınıf nesnesi oluşturmak istiyorum.
Şunu yapmak daha akıllıca olmaz mı?
Neden bu kaynağını geri versin ki, o zaman onun kaynağını ben edineyim.
Yani benim sınıf nesnem, diğer sınıf nesnesinin kaynağını edinmek için bu sefer gerçekten pointer'ı kopyalasın.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ama burada bir problem var.
Nedir bu problem?
Bir, koda bakarak, buradaki sınıf nesnesinin hayatının bitecek olduğunu anlaması gerekiyor derleyicinin.
Buraya dikkat.
Ve iki, alternatif başka bir kodu seçmesi gerekiyor.
Yani, şöyle bir durum oluşturmamız gerekiyor.
Eğer kopyalama hayatı devam edecek bir nesneden yapılıyorsa,
hayatı devam edecek bir nesne kaynak olarak kullanılması suretiyle yapılıyorsa,
o zaman bizim copy constructor'ımız perfectly fit istediğimiz o.
ama kopyalama, hayatı bitecek olan, asla bir daha kullanılmayacak olan bir nesneden yapılıyorsa,
o zaman arkadaşlar, deep copy yapmak yerine gerçekten pointer'ı kopyalayacak bir kodu seçmem gerekiyor.
Şimdi, bu yeni bir fikir değil ki.
Yani, bunu akletmek için çok zeki olmak gerekmiyor.
Fakat, modern C++'dan önce,
statik olarak, koda bakarak bunu yapma imkanı yoktu.
Ve, arkadaşlar,
modern C++'la birlikte,
bunun rahatlıkla implemente edilmesini sağlayacak bağlayıcı araç,
R-value reference, arkadaşlar.
Şimdi, çok dikkatli izleyelim.
Bir problem daha var.
O problem de şu.
Necati, senin dediğini yaptık.
Yani,
ikinci nesne, yeni hayata getireceğimiz nesne,
yeni bir kaynak edinmek yerine,
diğerinin pointer'ını kopyaladı.
Ama,
bu nesne için destructor çağrıldığında,
e o yine bu kaynağı geri vermeyecek mi?
Cevap tabii ki verecek.
O zaman da dangling pointer oluşur.
Fakat,
fakat şimdi biz,
öyle bir fonksiyon yazabilmeliyiz ki,
diğer nesnenin kaynağını çalmakla birlikte,
yani pointer'ı kopyalamakla birlikte,
diğer nesneyi de,
Resul,
Muhammed,
nasıl bir state'e sokması gerekiyor?
öyle bir state'e sokacak ki,
artık,
onun için destructor çağrıldığında,
destructor,
kaynağı geri vermeyecek.
Adeta kaynağının çalındığının farkında olacak,
ve kaynağı geri vermeyecek.
İşte,
bunu sağlayan fonksiyon,
move constructor.
Aynı şekilde,
bu sefer de şunu düşünün,
aynı şekilde,
önce biraz şöyle teori kısmına değinelim.
Aynı şekilde,
eğer,
iki tane ayrı nesne varsa,
ve biz,
kendisine atama yapacağımız nesnenin,
alacağı yeni değeri temsil eden,
diğer nesnenin,
artık yine,
kullanılır olmadığını biliyor isek,
yine,
bu nesnenin kaynağını çalabiliriz.
İşte,
bunu sağlayan fonksiyon da,
move assignment.
Yani,
move constructor ve move assignment,
öyle fonksiyonlar ki,
copy constructor ve copy assignment'a göre,
onlarla karşılaştırırsak,
yaptıkları iş,
kopyalama yapmamak,
deep copy yapmamak,
diğer nesnenin kaynağını çalmak,
ve diğer nesneyi,
sadece kaynağını çalmakla yetinmeyip,
diğer nesneyi,
destructor çağrıldığında,
diğer nesne için,
kaynağı geri vermemesini sağlamak.
İyi ama,
bunu nasıl yapacağız?
Arkadaşlar,
son derece basit.
Başka bir kodun,
kullanma ihtimali olmayan,
hayatı bitecek,
az önce söylediğim gibi,
gidici nesneler,
dilin kurallarına göre bu ifadeler,
bravo Yusuf Terha,
sağ taraf değeri.
O zaman,
iki tane constructor overloadu olsa,
biri,
sol taraf değeri argümanları alsa,
diğeri,
sağ taraf değeri argümanları alsa,
buraya dikkat,
arkadaşlar,
sağ taraf değeri,
argümanı alan,
overload,
neyi biliyor olacak?
Referansın bağlandığı,
nesnenin,
hayatının biteceğini,
başka bir kodun,
ona ihtiyaç duymadığını bilecek,
ve onun kaynağını çalacak.
Bir şeye dikkat edin,
hep karıştırılan bir nokta,
sağ taraf referansı,
bir referans,
yani sağ taraf referansı,
const olmak zorunda değil,
sağ taraf referansı,
bağlandığı nesneyi,
değiştirebilir mi?
Evet ya da hayır deyin,
çare hemen cevap verdi,
değiştirebilir mi?
Mütahitir.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Bakın nasıl,
lvalue referans,
lvalue ref,
const lvalue ref olabiliyorsa,
sağ taraf referansı da,
rvalue ref,
const rvalue ref olabilir.
Ama const olanı,
kullanacak bir semantik söz konusu değil.
O zaman,
bir fonksiyonun parametresi,
sağ taraf referansıysa,
o referansın,
bağlandığı nesneyi,
o referans yoluyla,
değiştirebiliriz.
Bu da hangi problemi çözüyor?
Çağrı,
Yusuf,
derha,
rasul,
hangi problemi çözüyor?
Diğer nesneyi,
destructible,
bir state'e,
sokacak.
Ama o destructible state,
kaynağı,
geri vermeyecek.
Şimdi o zaman,
hadi,
sınıfa,
birer,
arkadaşlar,
move,
constraktor ve move assignment ekleyelim.
Eğer bu fonksiyonları,
derleyicinin yazımına bırakırsanız,
arkadaşlar,
derleyicinin yazdığı move constraktor,
constraktor olduğu için,
ismi,
sınıfın ismiyle aynı.
Fakat,
parametresi,
arkadaşlar,
my class ref ref.
Yani sınıf türünden,
sağ taraf referansı.
Bakın bakın,
aradaki farka bakın.
Bu,
copy constraktor.
Bu ise,
move constraktor.
Şimdi burayı,
biraz yavaş geçeceğim.
Çünkü,
anladık gibi hissediyor,
programcıların çoğu.
Ama anlamamış olabiliyor.
O yüzden,
burada beni iyi dinlemenizi isteyeceğim.
Arkadaşlar,
aslında,
az önce verdiğim örneklerden,
hiçbir farkı yok.
Şimdi,
bunun,
constraktor olmasının dışında,
bir üye fonksiyonu olduğu açık.
Dolayısıyla,
bir fonksiyon değil mi?
bu bir overload mu?
Copy constraktor ile move constraktor,
birer overload mu?
kesinlikle.
O zaman,
my class sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi,
L value olan bir my class nesnesinden değerini alarak hayata getirmeye çalıştığımda,
bu çağrılacak değil mi?
ama,
R value olan bir sınıf nesnesini kaynak olarak kullandığımda,
bu çağrılacak.
Burayı herkes anladı mı?
Demek ki aslında,
copy constraktor ile move constraktor,
az önceki overload'un ta kendisi.
Biri,
constel value referans parametreli,
diğeri,
R value referans parametreli.
Dolayısıyla,
demin neden uzun uzun açıklama yaptığımı,
şimdi daha iyi anlayacaksınız.
İkisi de var ise,
çağrı,
Yusuf,
Cengiz Han,
ikisi de var ise,
L value'lar için,
copy constraktor çağrılacak,
R value argümanları için,
move constraktor çağrılacak.
Ama move constraktor bir nedenden yok ise,
o zaman,
hem L value,
hem R value için,
kim çağrılacak?
Copy constraktor çağrılacak.
İşte buna,
bravo,
fallback'i burada kullanıyoruz aslında.
Copy'e,
copy constraktora fallback olacak.
Yani,
bir sınıfın move constraktorının olmaması,
olağan bir durum,
olabilir de,
olmayabilir de.
Yani,
bazı sınıfların,
örneğin,
move constraktoru yok.
Ama move constraktorının olmaması,
o sınıflar türünden,
nesnelerin,
R value expression,
argümanlarla hayata getirilebileceği gerçeğini değiştirmiyor,
değil mi?
Evet.
Böylece,
ne sağlamış olacağız?
Bakın,
bakın,
hayatı devam etmekte olan,
nesnelerin,
kaynak olarak kullanılması durumunda,
onun kaynağını çalmak,
o nesneyi kullanan kodların başını belaya sokar.
Böyle bir şeye asla girmemeliyiz.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
O zaman onun kaynağını çalmamalıyız.
İşte o zaman,
bu fonksiyon çağrılacak.
Ama,
constraktora gelen argümanın,
R value expression olması,
onun kaynağının,
güvenli bir şekilde,
çalınabileceğine,
işaret ediyor.
Onu da,
bu overload alacak,
ve arkadaşlar,
kaynağını çalacak.
diğer nesneyi de,
destructible bir stekle bırakacak.
Böylece,
destructor çağrıldığında,
artık kaynağı geri vermeyecek.
Aynı durum,
atamalar için de geçerli.
Şimdi de atamalara bakalım.
Bu,
pazartesi günü gördüğümüz,
meşhur,
copy assignment.
Uzun uzun konuştuk.
const,
my class,
ref.
Eğer şimdi buraya,
bir de şöyle bir fonksiyon koyarsam,
tıkkı,
constructor,
move constructor,
çiftinde olduğu gibi,
bu da bir overload.
Hatta öyle bir overload ki,
L value'ları için,
14. satırdaki,
atama,
operatör fonksiyonu çağrılacak.
Ama R value argümanı için,
yani eşitlerin sağındaki,
atama operatörünün sağ operanda olan ifade,
R value expression ise,
o zaman da bu çağrılacak.
Yine aynı şekilde,
buradaki atamada,
bir kopyalama yapılacak.
Ama buradaki atamada,
kaynak çalınacak.
İşte o kaynağını çalmaya aslında taşıma diyoruz.
Arkadaşlar,
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Kaynağını çalmaya taşıma diyoruz.
Evet.
Necati şimdi mesela,
string sınıfı böyle mi?
Hiç şüpheniz olmasın.
Standart kütüphanede,
başta container sınıfları olmak üzere,
bazı sınıflar,
arkadaşlar,
taşıma semantiğinden yoğun olarak faydalanıyor.
Mesela vector sınıfını düşünün.
Hem böyle bir konstruktörü var,
hem de böyle bir konstruktörü var.
Hem böyle bir atama operatör fonksiyonu var,
hem de böyle bir atama operatör fonksiyonu var.
Şimdi modern C++'ın,
gerçekten de getirdiği en önemli avantajlardan biri,
bu taşıma semantiği.
Neden?
Çünkü taşıma semantiği implemente edilmeseydi,
gerçekten eskisi C++'da böyleydi.
Aslında hiçbir kopyalama yapılmayacak durumlarda,
gereksiz yere kopyalama yapılıyordu.
Arkadaşlar,
kopyalama deyip geçmeyin,
sınıfın ne olduğuna bağlı olarak,
kopyalama maliyeti,
olağanüstü yüksek olabilir.
Yani kopyalama yerine taşıma,
daha fazla efficiency sağlar mı?
It depends,
sınıfın ne olduğuna bağlı.
Burada da o kadar çok yanlış anlama var ki,
arkadaşlar,
mesela bazı arkadaşlarım da şöyle zannediyor,
taşıma geldi,
yani örneğin copy konstruktörü var,
move konstruktörü var,
o zaman move konstruktör her zaman bir avantaj sağlar.
Hayır, hayır.
Move konstruktörün her zaman bir avantaj sağlayacağını söyleyemeyiz.
Çünkü move konstruktörün bir avantaj sağlaması için,
ortada bir kaynağın olması,
o kaynağı kopyalama alternatifine karşı,
kopyalamayı tamamen ortadan kaldırıp,
o kaynağı çalma, edinme,
o kaynağın yeni sahibi olma seçeneğini,
ya da alternatifini kullanmış oluyoruz.
Peki,
şimdi derleyicinin yazdığı move konstruktörün nasıl bir koda sahip olduğunu,
yine daha önceki örneklerdeki sözde sınıfımız için bulacağım,
buralarda bir yerde gösterelim.
Evet, evet.
Dedik ki,
böyle bir my class sınıfımız olsun.
Arkadaşlar,
bu hatta en son,
kopyalayan atama operatör fonksiyonunun,
kodunun ne şekilde olduğunu,
arkadaşlar,
göstermişiz.
Tabi,
sentaks için,
A, B, C sınıflarını oluşturmak yerine,
şöyle,
tek sosyası üstünde gösterelim.
Şimdi sınıfın,
arkadaşlar,
move konstruktörü,
buraya dikkat,
bakın bu copy konstruktör,
ne yaptığını görüyorsunuz.
Derleyicinin yazdığı move konstruktör,
az önce söylediğim gibi,
konstruktör bir kere,
ismi sınıf ismiyle aynı,
fakat,
arkadaşlar,
parametresi sağ taraf referansı.
Şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin.
Derleyicinin yazdığı move konstruktör,
elemanlara taşıma yapıyor,
kopyalama yapmıyor.
Yani elemanları da,
copy konstruktörlama hayata getirecek,
move konstruktörlama.
Cevap,
Yani,
A, B, C sınıflarının,
Yusuf,
hem copy konstruktörü,
hem move konstruktörü varsa,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
move konstruktör,
A, X, B, X, C, X'i,
bu sınıfların,
copy konstruktörüne yapılan çağrıyla mı oluşturacak,
yoksa move konstruktörüne yapılan çağrıyla mı oluşturacak?
Cevap,
move konstruktörlerine yapılacak çağrıyla oluşturacak.
Peki,
soru,
o zaman,
şöyle yazsam,
işimi halleder miyim?
nasıl olsa sağ taraf değeri olan sınıf nesneleri için bu çağrılıyor.
Evet ya da hayır deyin.
Cevap,
hayır.
Bravo.
Neden?
Bakın bakın,
her ne kadar bu move konstruktörü olsa da,
R,
bir R value referansı olsa da,
hatırlayınız,
isim formundaki ifadeler,
L value kategorisinde.
Yani,
R'nin,
R value referansı olması,
R nokta A,
X ifadesinin,
R value expression olması sonucunu doğuruyor mu?
Yoksa,
R nokta A,
X,
R nokta B,
R nokta C,
X,
bunlar halen L value mu?
Bakınız,
bravo,
bunlar halen L value.
Bakınız,
en sık yapılan taşıma semantiğini yanlış algılama biçimi hatası,
L value,
R value referansı data type ile,
yani bir değişkenin data type ile,
o değişkenin oluşturduğu ifadenin,
value kategorisini birbiriyle karıştırmak.
O zaman,
burada,
A,
X için,
B,
C,
X için,
bu sınıfların,
mu konstruktörünün çağrılmasını sağlamak istesek,
o zaman,
bu ifadelerin,
L value değil,
R value olmasını sağlamalıyız.
İşte,
normalde,
L value iken,
bravo,
onu,
compile time'da,
bir R value expression olarak,
kullanılmasını sağlayan,
mu fonksiyonu.
Mu fonksiyonu.
Keşke bunun ismi,
bence mu bir yerine,
mu cast olsaydı.
Ya da,
R value cast olsaydı.
O zaman,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
mu konstruktör,
böyle.
Arkadaşlar,
yani,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
mu konstruktör,
elemanlarında,
mu konstruktörle hayata,
getirilmesini sağlıyor.
Son derece,
açık.
Fatih Akgül diyor ki,
mesela,
R cast olabilirdi.
Olabilirdi valla.
R value cast,
tabi uzun,
isim yazmaktansa,
Fatih'in önerisi de gayet güzel.
Bu fonksiyonun ismi,
R cast olabilirdi.
İşte,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
mu konstruktör,
böyle.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
özellikle,
bana,
telegramdan soru zormuş,
arkadaşım vardı,
Rasul.
Rasul,
siz de özellikle,
daha dikkatli izleyin şimdi.
Mesela,
şöyle bir snap olsaydı,
class,
match,
match'in,
elemanları,
örneğin,
string türünden olsaydı,
yani,
kaynak kullanan,
bir nesne,
match'in elemanlarından biri,
yine,
bir container nesnesi,
dinamik dizi nesnesi,
örneğin,
stu vektör olsaydı.
Şimdi,
bu sınıfın,
mu konstruktörünü,
ben yazmasam,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
mu konstruktör,
bir match nesnesini,
ayağına getiren,
bir,
r value match nesnesi olduğunda,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
mu konstruktör çağrılacaktı.
Derleyicinin yazdığı,
mu konstruktör,
match'in,
str elemanını,
string sınıfının,
mu konstruktörıyla,
hayata getirecekti.
Yani,
hayata gelen,
match nesnesi,
kaynak olarak kullanılan,
match nesnesinin,
stringinin,
kaynağını çalacaktı.
Vektörün,
Benim bu durumda,
bir şey yapmam gerekiyor mu?
Hayır.
Ama,
ama,
yine,
bizim,
birazdan,
string sınıfına,
geri döneceğim,
bizim string sınıfımızda olduğu gibi,
eğer,
handle elemanlar varsa,
taşıma semantinin,
implementasyonunu,
kendim yapmalıyım.
Neden?
E,
çünkü,
kopyalama yapmak yerine,
sadece,
pointer'ı,
kopyalayacağım,
ve diğer nesneyi,
arkadaşlar,
destruktör'a çağrıldığı zaman,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bir sorun oluşturmayacak,
state'e,
getireceğim.
hadi onu yapalım.
Gelin,
bizim string sınıfımız için,
bir,
move constructor yazalım.
Arkadaşlar,
bu arada bakın,
tekrar söylüyorum.
Move copy constructor'ın,
derleyici tarafından yazılması,
eğer sınıfımın,
eğer sınıfımın elemanları,
ya da elemanlarından biri,
handle ise,
felakete neden oluyor.
Ama,
sınıfın move constructor'ının olmaması,
yani,
olması daha iyiyken,
olmaması,
bir felaket senaryosu değil.
Sadece,
efficiency açısından zararı var.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Mesela,
ben string sınıfını böyle bıraksaydım.
Burası çok önemli.
Ben string sınıfını böyle bıraksaydım.
Yani,
copy constructor'ı var,
copy assignment'ı var.
Fakat,
move constructor'ı ve move assignment'ı yok.
Bu,
undefined behavior oluşturur muydu?
Böyle bir sınıfın kullanımı,
normal kullanımı,
yani,
kullanan kodla.
Hayır.
Ama,
neye neden olabilirdi?
Kaveh,
Oğuzhan,
taşımanın,
dini anlamda söylemiyorum,
nimetlerinden faydalanmak yerine,
gidip yine,
çok daha yüksek maliyetli,
kopyalama yapacağım senaryolar olurdu.
Dolayısıyla,
move constructor ve move assignment'ın varlığı,
arkadaşlar,
bir hata durumuna engellemekten ziyade,
nedir?
Daha verimli hale getirmek,
gereksiz kopyalamalardan kaçınmak.
Bakın,
bu kadar basit.
Move constructor ve move assignment,
varlık nedenleri,
gereksiz kopyalamalardan kaçınmak,
gereksiz kopyalama yerine,
kopyalamayı ortadan kaldırıp,
kaynağın,
bir nesneden,
adeta bir nesneye,
geçmesini sağlamak.
Peki,
böyle bir string sınıfı nesnesi için,
move constructor nasıl yazılmalı?
Hadi,
yazmaya çalışalım.
Bir kere,
yine,
derleyicinin yazdığı,
efendim,
parametrik yapıda yazacağım.
Yani,
fonksiyonun parametriyesi,
rvalue referans.
Arkadaşlar,
izleyin.
normalde ben,
mp'nin,
copy constructor'da,
değerini,
yeni allocate ettiğim,
bellek bloğunun adresi yapmıştım.
Ama bakın,
şimdi ne yapıyorum?
mp,
other'ın mp'si.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Resmen,
pointer'ı kopyaladım.
Böylece,
bu kopyalamayla,
benim nesnem,
aslında,
zaten,
diğer nesnenin,
allocate ettiği,
bellek bloğunun,
adresini tutmuş oldu.
Yani,
bu veri elemanı,
mp isimli veri elemanı.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Yine aynı şekilde,
arkadaşlar,
len'i de,
kopyalayabilirim.
Onda da bir sakınca yok.
O zaman,
onu da,
uygun sırayla yazayım.
mlen,
other'ın,
mlen'i.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ama,
bir problem daha var.
Bakın şimdi,
string sınıfının destraktörüne,
tekrar bakacak olursak,
string sınıfının destraktörü,
mp'nin,
değeri olan adres,
null pointer değilse,
kriye ediyor.
Şimdi,
yine,
belki anlamakta,
biraz zorluk çekilen noktalardan biri burası.
Biz nesnenin kaynağını çaldık,
çalmasına,
çünkü pointer'ı kopyaladık.
Ama,
diğer nesnenin,
mp'sinin,
değeri de aynı.
Sanki şöyle bir,
durum varmış gibi düşünüyor.
Bu adamın çok yapıldığını düşünüyorum.
Biz onun kaynağını çaldık ya,
sanki o destroy olmayacak.
Other isimli,
referansın,
bağlandığı nesne içinde,
destraktör çağrılacak mı?
Aa,
evet,
veya hayır.
cevap,
evet.
Peki,
onun için destraktör çağrılırsa,
halen onun,
mp isimli pointer'ı,
null pointer değil ki.
Onun,
mp isimli,
veri elemanı olan pointer,
halen,
aynı değerde.
O zaman,
onu,
onun için destraktör çağrıldığında,
bizim çaldığımız kaynağı,
onun geri vermemesini sağlamalıyız,
değil mi?
Peki,
bunu nasıl yapacağız?
Ya,
son derece basit.
mp pointer'ına,
bravo Fatih,
null pointer değeri atacağız.
Tabii,
burayı daha sonra,
biraz daha detaylı konuşmalıyız.
Arkadaşlar,
örneğin,
mlen değişkenine de,
sıfır değerini,
atayabilirim.
other'ın mp'si yazmamışım.
other'ın mp'si,
null pointer,
other'ın,
yazdım zannettim,
other'ın mleni,
eşittir sıfır.
Buraya da,
daha sonra geri döneceğim.
Bunun gereksiz olduğunu düşünebilirsiniz.
Ama neden gerekli olduğu konusunda,
daha sonra konuşacağız.
Evet,
işte bu kadar.
Yani,
move constructor dediğim,
bu kadar basit.
Böylece,
bakın,
eğer ben,
şöyle bir kod yazarsam,
elimde,
bir string nesnesi var,
arkadaşlar,
ya da yeni bir string nesnesi oluşturmak istiyorum.
Ama,
argüman olarak verdiğim,
string nesnesi,
rvalue expression.
Arkadaşlar,
yani örneğin,
string,
bugün,
yine,
çok,
sıcak,
bir,
hava,
vardı.
Cümlenin,
mantığıyla ilgilenmeyiniz.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın,
bu,
rvalue expression mi?
Evet.
Çünkü,
temporal object.
Daha sonra detaylı göreceğiz.
O zaman bu bir rvalue expression.
O zaman hangi fonksiyon çağrılacak?
Bu fonksiyon çağrılacak.
Yani,
move constructor çağrılacak.
Move constructor da bu nesnenin kaynağını kopyalamak yerine,
onun kaynağını çalacak.
Buraya kadar takip edebildik mi?
Arkadaşlar,
burada yalnız,
enteresan bir durum var.
İşte,
en fazla kafa karıştıran durumlardan biri.
Eğer,
böyle bir durumda,
yani,
string sınıfında olduğu gibi,
sdl'in,
container sınıfları diyeceğimiz,
daha sonra öğreneceğimiz sınıflarda olduğu gibi,
sınıfın hem copy constructorı,
hem move constructorı varsa,
bakın,
aslında bizim bir şey yapmamız gerekmiyor.
Yani,
siz şöyle bir düşünecek misiniz?
Copy constructorımı çağrılsın,
move constructorımı?
Hayır,
hayır,
o sizi ilgilendirmiyor ki.
Sizin,
argüman olarak verdiğiniz ifade,
rvalue expression ise,
derleyici,
function overload resolution ile,
move constructorı seçecek,
lvalue expression ise,
o zaman copy constructorı seçecek.
Yani,
sizin taşıma semantinden,
kodu yazan programcı olarak,
bir sınıfı kullanırken,
mesela,
sdl'in stl'in stl string,
stl vektör,
stl list gibi sınıflarını kullanırken,
şöyle bir endişe duymanıza gerek yok.
Efendim,
ben move constructorı çağırayım da,
daha etkili olsun.
Tipik olarak,
altın çizim,
böyle bir endişeye gerek yok.
Çünkü,
verdiğiniz argüman,
L-Value ise Copy Constructor çağrılacak, R-Value ise Move Constructor çağrılacak.
Böylece arkadaşlar hayatı devam etmekte olan nesnelerin kaynağını çalmayacağız.
Şöyle nesneler hemen Persistent nesneler diyorum.
Ama hayata bitecek başka kodun onu kullanmayacağı nesneler.
Onun için de böyle popüler kullanılan İngilizce nitelice ephemeral yani bir mevsim hayatı bitecek anlamında onun için de Move Constructor çağrılacak.
Burayı anladık mı? Ama bir özel durumdan bahsedeceğim birazdan biraz sabırlı olursanız tabii.
Şimdi mülakatlarda C++ programcılarıyla yapılan mülakatlarda herhalde orada da ben bir rekor kırmış olabilirim.
Çünkü çok fazla mülakat yapıyorum işim gereği.
Programcıların neyi yanlış anladığını siz onlarla konuştukça, mülakat yaptıkça daha iyi anlıyorsunuz.
Ya da onların yazdığı kodlara baktıkça.
Benim de en fazla yanlış anlaşıldığını gördüğüm yerler olduğu için taşıma semantiğiyle ilgili onunla ilgili sorular soruyorum.
Mesela sorduğum sorulardan biri şu.
İzleyin arkadaşlar.
Diyorum ki burada bir MyClass nesnesi var.
MyClass M.
Şunları da ya da string de olabilir ama şimdilik sildeyim.
Buraya geri döneceğim.
Herhangi bir sınıf olsun taşıma semantiğinden faydalanabilecek.
Class MyClass.
Arkadaşlar.
Burada da şöyle bir fonksiyon olsun.
VoidFunk.
MyClass.
Refref.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Diyorum ki soru.
Hatta bakın fonksiyonun şu anda kodu.
Kod olsun.
Soru.
Konk fonksiyonuna çağrı yapıyorum.
My'yi örneğin sağ taraf değeri haline getirmek için.
ona sağ taraf değeri haline getirecek ifadeyi.
StudMove fonksiyonunu kullanıyorum.
Ve şu soruyu soruyorum.
Size de soruyorum.
19. satırdan sonra
My nesnesinin kaynağı çalınmış mıdır?
Bravo.
Bakın bu sefer neredeyse herkes doğru cevap verdi.
Tabii ki hayır.
Yani bir nesneyi
bir sağ taraf referansına bağlamak
onun kaynağını çalmak demek değil.
Hiçbir alakası yok.
Ne alaka?
Referans bildiğiniz pointer.
Yani siz şimdi bunun assembly koduna baksanız
aslında assembly kodda neyi göreceksiniz?
Funk'ın parametresi bir pointer
ve MyClass nesnesinin adresine oluyor.
Peki kaynağın çalınmasını sağlayan ne olacak?
Burayı çok dikkatli izleyelim.
Arkadaşlar.
Siz bu sağ taraf referansı.
Bravo Alp Yıldırım.
Bravo.
Funk içindeki implementasyon.
Süper cevap.
Yani funk içinde öyle bir implementasyon olmalı ki
bu sağ taraf referansının bağlandığı nesnenin
kaynağını çalmalı.
Onun da iki tane yolu var.
Ya bir MyClass nesnesini
hayata getireceğim
ya da bir MyClass nesnesine
atama yapacağım.
Burayı anladık mı?
Ya bir MyClass nesnesini
hayata getireceğim
ya da bir MyClass nesnesine
atama yapacağım.
Peki MyClass mx eşittir r.
Şimdi soruya cevap vermeye çalışacağım.
Bu kod 17. satırdaki m'nin kaynağını çalmış olur mu?
A olur, B olmaz.
Alihan Bozkur olur diyor.
Alp Yıldırım olur diyor.
Doğru cevap olmaz.
Olmaz.
Neden olmaz?
Hep aynı yere gelin.
Neden o kadar sık tekrar ettiğimi görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Peki bu ifade L value mu R value mu?
Cevap L value.
Bu ifade L value olduğuna göre
o zaman buradaki mx için
copy constructor mu çağrılacak?
Move constructor mu çağrılacak?
Cevap copy constructor çağrılacak.
O zaman kaynağı çalmayacak ki kopyalayacak.
Peki kaynağı çalması için
buradaki mx'i
hayata getirirken
kullandığımız nesnenin
r value expression olması gerekir değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
peki nasıl onu r value expression yapacağız?
Yine stud mu ile.
Şimdi espriyi anladınız mı?
İşte böyle bir kod varsa
bu fonksiyon
kendisine gelen nesnenin
kaynağını çalar.
Çünkü mx
mu construct edilir.
Gelin durumu biraz
toparlayalım.
Şimdi mean'i boş verin
arkadaşlar
bu tür durumlarda
tipik alternatif yapı şu
birçok örneğini göreceksiniz.
Çok çok dikkatli izleyin şimdi.
Tıpkı
copy constructor mu constructer
da olduğu gibi
iki tane ayrı overload olacak.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi böyle iki overload olursa
oraya geleceğim.
Sağ taraf değerini
yukarıdaki alacak değil mi?
Sol taraf değerini
aşağıdaki alacak.
O zaman biz
üsttekinin
implementasyonunda
r'nin
bağlandığı nesnenin
kaynağını
çalacağız.
alttaki
implementasyonda
r'nin
bağlandığı
nesnenin
kaynağını
kopyalayacağız.
İşte bu kadar.
En çok
kullanılan
yapılardan biri
işte
l-value
ve r-value
için
ayrı fonksiyon
yazmak.
l-value
için yazılan
fonksiyonun
bir
kopyalama
yapmasını
sağlamak.
Ama
r-value
alan
fonksiyonun
kopyalama
yerine
taşıma
yapmasını
sağlamak.
O zaman
tekrar edelim.
Siz bir
sağ taraf
değeri
nesneyi
sağ taraf
referansına
bağlayarak
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanmış
olmuyorsunuz.
Kavey
az önce
güzel bir cümle
yazdı.
Sadece
taşıma
semantiğini
zemin
hazırlamış
oluyorsunuz.
Taşıma
semantiğini
gerçekleştiren
taşımayı
burada
bu referansın
bağlandığı
nesneyi
kullanarak
yeni bir
nesne
oluşturmanız
ya da
birazdan
mu ve
segment'e
geldiğimizde
göreceğiz
var olan
bir nesneyi
atama
yapmanız.
Bakın
şimdi
bunun
ben size
çok tipik
bir örneğini
göstereyim
arkadaşlar.
İzleyin
lütfen.
Bakın
çok tipik
bir örnek.
Vektör
nasıl bir
sınıf
yani
hiç
bilmeniz
gerekmiyor.
Ben biraz
bahsedeceğim
dinamik
dizi
sınıfı.
İleride
çok detaylı
göreceğiz.
Yani
dinamik
dizi
veri
yapısını
dynamic
array
data
structure'ı
implemente
eden
ona uygun
bir
interfej
sağlayan
standart
kütüphanemizin
o
STL
standart
template
library
dediğimiz
bileşeninin
belki de
en sık
kullanılan
birkaç
sınıfından
biri.
Biri
string
biri
vektör.
Arkadaşlar
çok dikkatli
izlemenizi
istiyorum ama
bakalım yakalayabilecek
misiniz
buradaki
küçük
ayrıntıyı.
Pushback
fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor?
İsminden
bile
anlayabilirsiniz.
Dinamik
diziye
sondan
ekleme
yapıyor.
Öyle
değil mi?
Dinamik
diziye
sondan
ekleme
yapıyor.
Yani
diyelim ki
benim
bir
vektör
neslem var.
İsmi
vek
olsun.
Ben
vekin
pushback
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
arkadaşlar
aslında
vektördeki
dinamik
dizideki
öe sayısı
onken
on birinciyi
eklemiş
oluyorum.
Takip
edebiliyor
musunuz?
Şu
eklediğim
on birinci
öe
yani vektördeki
son öe
olacak ki
bu da
biliyorsunuz
amortize
constant time
algoritmadır.
O zaman
o değerini
arktan alıyor
değil mi?
peki
şimdi
soru
sizce
pushback
fonksiyonunun
bir tane
mi
overloadu
var
iki tane
mi
overloadu
var?
Cevap
kesinlikle
iki tane
overloadu
var.
Neden
iki tane
overloadu
var?
Ya son
derece
basit.
Eğer
bir tane
overloadu
olsaydı
bu
hem
l value
r value
için
bu
çağrılsaydı
o zaman
kopyalama yapmak
kaçınılmaz
olurdu
değil mi?
Yani
vektörde
son eleman
olarak
tutulacak
nesneyi
hayata
copy
constructorla
getirecektik.
Ama
şimdi
bizim ne
yapmamız
gerekiyor?
Vektörü
düşünün
kafamızı
hatta
şöyle bir
şekilde
çizeyim
arkadaşlar
tüm
yeteneksizliğime
karşın
şu
bizim
vektörümüzdeki
diyelim ki
sınıf
nesneleri
örneğin
stringler
vektör
dinamik dizide
string tutuluyor.
şu anda
üç tane
öde
bir de
benden
dört tane
v olsun.
Pushback
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak.
Pushback
fonksiyonu
şu bellek
alanında
onun
rengini
farklı
yapayım.
Şu bellek
alanında
bir
string
nesnesini
hayata
getirecek.
Şimdi
iki tane
seçenek
var.
Bu
bellek
alanında
hayata
getireceği
vektördeki
son eleman
olan
string
nesnesi
için
string
sınıfının
copy
konstruktörünü
çağırabilir.
String
sınıfının
move
konstruktörünü
çağırabilir.
Peki
bunu
nasıl
gerçekleştiriyor?
Son derece
basit.
Pushback
fonksiyonunun
iki tane
overloadu
var.
Şimdi
kafamızda
basitleştirilmiş
şekilde
vektör
sınıfını
düşünelim.
Mesela
vektör
sınıfı
sözde
normalde
tabii
jenerik bir
sınıf
ama ben
konu anlaşılsın
diye
vektörün
şöyle bir sınıf
olduğunu
varsayayım.
str
vektör
yani
dinamik dizide
stringler
tutuluyor.
Bakın şimdi
fonksiyonlardan
biri şöyle
void
pushback
const
string
ref
hadi
standart
kütüphanenin
string
sınıfı
olsun
arkadaşlar.
const
string
ref
fakat
diğer
pushback
overloadu
şöyle
const
olmayan
st
string
ref
şimdi
ben
st
vektör
sınıfı
türünden
bir
konteyner
nesnem
olsa
arkadaşlar
ve de
elimde
if
string
nesnem
olsa
st
string
s
necati
ergin
svec
nokta
pushback
s
dediğim zaman
derleyici
koda
bakacak
s'in
lvalue
expression
olduğunu
anlayacak
ve
function
overload
resolution
da bu
pushback'i
çağıracak.
Bu
pushback'in
kodu
nasıl
implemente
edilmiş
tekrar
resmimize
geri dönelim
bu
benlek
alanında
hayata
getireceği
nesne
için
string
sınıfının
copy
constructor'ını
çağıracak.
Ama
şimdi
diğer
overload'a
bakalım
eğer
argüman
olan
ifade
bir
sağ
taraf
değeri
olsaydı
mesela
bu
bir
sağ
taraf
değeri
o
zaman
derleyici
bunun
bir
rvalue
expression
olduğunu
anlayacaktı
ve
bu
fonksiyonu
çağıracaktı.
Peki
bu
fonksiyonun
kodu
nasıl
çalışacak?
Tekrar
resme
geri dönelim.
Burada
hayata
getireceği
string
nesnesini
sınıfının
copy
constructor'ı
ile değil
move
constructor'ı
ile
hayata
getirecek.
Böylece
diğer
nesnenin
kaynağını
çalacak.
Buraya
kadar
anladıysanız
çok
iyi
bir
noktadayız
arkadaşlar.
Herkes
anladı mı?
Bu
iki
overload'un
birbirinden
farkını
evet.
Ama
şimdi
tekrar
başa
geri
dönelim.
Arkadaşlar
move
constructor'ın
bir
fayda
sağlaması
gerekiyor
implement edilmesi
için.
Yoksa
move
constructor'ın
sağladığı
ilave bir
fayda
yoksa
mesela bir
örnek vereyim.
Çok
dikkatli
izleyin.
Şöyle
bir
sınıfınız
olsaydı
class
my
private
arkadaşlar
int
are
bin
diğer elemanların
konuyla alakası
olmadığını
düşünün.
Şimdi
soru
my
class
sınıfı
nesneleri
kendi
işlerinde
abarttım
tabi böyle
bir senaryo
abartılmış
ama
bin elemanlı
bir int
dizi
içeriyorlar.
Şimdi
bu sınıf
için
move
constructor
yazmanın
bu sınıfın
ayrı
copy
constructor'ının
dışında
bir de
move
constructor'ının
olması
efficiency
açısından
bir fayda
sağlar mı?
Cevap
hayır.
Çünkü
derleyiciye
de bıraksanız
sonuçta
dizinin
kopyalanması
gerekecek.
Yani
elimde bir
pointer yok ki
o pointer'ın
gösterdiği
kaynağı
kendi
kaynağımı
yapayım.
Burayı
anladınız mı?
Mesela
bu sınıfı
için
move
constructor'ın
burada da
çok tipik
bir yanlış
anlama var.
Zaman ediyorlar ki
başta da bunu
söyledim.
Move
constructor
er derde
deva.
Ne alakası var?
Şimdi
move
constructor'ın
ses alacağı
hiçbir fayda
yok.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Evet.
Ama
olsaydı
dikkatli
izleyelim
eğer şöyle
olsaydı
örneğin
burada
bir pointer
olsaydı
bu pointer
binamik olarak
allocate edilmiş
bir bellek
bloğundaki
string
nesnelerinin
bulunduğu
bir bellek
bloğunun
adresini
tutuyor
olsaydı
move
constructor
burada
hayati
önem taşırdı.
Çünkü bakın
kopyalama
semantiğiyle
yetinirseniz
sizin
kopyalama
yoluyla
hayata
getireceğiniz
nesne
gidecek
ayrı bir
bellek
alanı
allocate
edecek
ve
üstelik
orada
string
nesnelerini
oluşturacak.
Yani
diğerinin
allocate
ettiği
bellek
bloğunda
10 bin
tane
string
nesnesi
varsa
sizin
hayata
getirdiğiniz
nesne de
o 10 bin
tane
string
nesnesini
hayata
getirecek.
Burada
inanılmaz
yüksek
bir
maliyet
söz konusu
olabilir.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Peki
şimdi
gelelim
move
assignment'a.
Arkadaşlar
benzer
şekilde
bir sınıf
nesnesine
bir
R-value
expression
sınıf
nesnesine
atadığımızda
aslında
atama
operatörünün
sağ
tarafındaki
nesnenin
artık
bir daha
kullanılmayacağını
biliyor
olsak da
eğer
move
assignment
dediğimiz
fonksiyon
olmasaydı
orada
kopyalama
yapmaya
zorlamış
olacaktık.
Necati
o zaman
aynısı
olacak.
Kesinlikle
kesinlikle
bakın bakın
tekrar buraya
geri dönelim.
Şimdi de
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
sınıf için
derleyicinin
yazdığı
move
assignment
nasıl bir
fonksiyon
onu görelim.
izleyin.
Bakın
bu
copy
constructor
hatta
hepsini
birlikte
görelim
hem
tekrar
etmiş
oluruz.
Şu
copy
constructor
yanına
yorum
satırı
ile
ekleyeyim.
Copy
constructor
altındaki
move
constructor
derleyicinin
yazdığı
bu arada
her biri
için şunu
tekrar etmem
gerekiyordu
ama
etmedim.
Hepsi
için
tekrar
ettiğimi
düşünün.
Derleyicinin
yazdığı
move
constructor
yine sınıfın
non-static
inline
public
dünya
fonksiyonu.
Şu
copy
assignment
my
class
ref
arkadaşlar
operatör
atamı
const
my
class
ref
re
ax
eşittir
re'nin
ax
bx
eşittir
re'nin
bx
cx
eşittir
re'nin
cx
ve
return
yıldız
this
şimdi
geldik
derleyicinin
yazdığı
move
assignment'a
derleyicinin
yazdığı
move
assignment
fonksiyonu
yine
geri dönüş
değeri
sınıf
türünden
l-value
referans
fakat
parametresi
const
sınıf
türünden
l-value
referans
yerine
yine
r-value
referans
arkadaşlar bu arada bir şeyde
dikkat etmenizi istiyorum
bakın
bizim
string sınıfı için yazdığımız
deminki kodda
diğer nesnenin
pointer'ını
null pointer yaptık ya
şöyle bir kod yazdık ya
other
dot
mp
null
ptr
bunu yapabilmemiz
için
referans
değişkenin
const olmaması
gerekiyor
o yüzden
move
constructor
assignment
bunların parametreleri
const olmayan
r-value
referans
const olan
r-value
referans
yapsaydık
re'nin
diğer örnek
için söylüyorum
other'ın
mp
s eşittir
null pointer
dediğimizde
zaten
syntax hatası
olurdu
peki
tahmin edin bakalım
o zaman
sağ taraf değeri
argümanlar için
bu çağrılacak
eğer ben kodu yine
böyle yazsaydım
ki doğru olmayacaktı
elemanlar
yine
copy assignment'la
kendilerini
atama yapmış
olacaktık
çünkü
bu
ifadeler
birer
l-value
expression
r'nin
r-value
reference
data type
sahip olması
bu ifadeleri
l-value
expression
yapmıyor
o zaman
sadece ne değişecek
yusuf
barış
rassol
burada
yine
molcast
yapmak
durumunda
öyle değil mi
ax eşittir
bx eşittir
cx eşittir
bu kadar
ama
arkadaşlar
bu derleyicinin
yazdığı
molkonstruktör
şimdi biz
sınıf için
molkonstruktör'ı
yazdığımızda
neye de dikkat
etmemiz gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
evet
diğer nesnenin
kaynağını
çalacağız
diğer nesneyi
yine
destroy
edilebilecek
bir durumda
bırakacağız
ama
aynı zamanda
bu işlemleri
yapmadan önce
kendi kaynağımızı da
geri vereceğiz
o zaman
tekrar
para vermeden
o koda
geri dönersek
biraz bekleteceğim
bakın çok büyük
bir batur tutuyor
süper
geldik
evet
şöyle bir daha
bakalım
string sınıfının
copy
konstruktör'ı
string sınıfının
move
konstruktör'ı
string sınıfının
copy
assignment
function'ı
ama
bir de şimdi
buraya
move
assignment
yazıyoruz
evet
sıfırdan
yazalım
önce
parametrik
yapısı
string
ref döndüren
operatör
atama
string
ref
other
mecate
eğer böyle
yapıyorsak
zaten ben
sormadan
Fatih
sormuş
yine
self
assignment
kontrolü
yapmalı
mıyız
kesinlikle
yine
self
assignment
kontrolü
yapmalısınız
ama
işte o
copy
swap
videomunu
kullansaydık
self
assignment
kontrolü
yapmamıza
gerek
kalmayacaktı
if
this
eşit eşit
address of
other
return
start this
ama
şimdi
önce
kendi
kaynağımızı
geri vereceğiz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
free
şuradaki kodu
şu atamalar olacak
ama önce
kaynağı geri verelim
şimdi
mlen eşittir
other'ın
mleni
mp eşittir
other'ın
mp'si
bakın
eğer
şunu yazmasaydık
kaynak
sızıntısı
olurdu
değil mi
pointer'a yeni bir değer
atamamız
o pointer'ın
gösterdiği
kaynağın
geri verildiği
anlamına
gelmiyor
mp eşittir
other'ın
mp'si
şimdi kaynak
çalma kısmı
tamamlandı
ama
diğer nesneyi de
yine
destroyable
bir state'e
sokmak için
other'ın
mp'si
eşittir
null pointer
ve
other'ın
bunu konuşacağız
demiştik
mleni
eşittir
sıfır
return
start this
bu kadar
görecek
örnek sınıfımız için
move
konstruktör'ı
copy
move assignment'ı
copy assignment'ı
implemente etmiş olduk
şimdi
hem Russell
hem de diğer
arkadaşlarım için
eğer
ben bu sınıfı
böyle yazmışsam
örneğin
Kaveh
Fatih
Ozan
kendi yazacağı
sınıflarda
sınıflardan
herhangi birinde
ya da birden
fazlasında
benim
string sınıfım
türünden
elemanlar
koyarsa
o zaman
kendi yazacağı sınıflar
için
copy
konstruktör
move
copy
assignment
move
yazmasına
başka bir neden
yoksa
tabii gerek
olacak mı?
hayır
derleyicinin yazdığı
copy
konstruktör
benim yazdığım
sınıfın
copy
konstruktör'ını
derleyicinin yazdığı
move
konstruktör
benim sınıfımın
move
konstruktör'ını
derleyicinin yazdığı
efendim
copy
assignment
benim
sınıfımın
copy
assignment'ını
nokta nokta
çağıracak
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet
ama şimdi
çok özel
biraz da zor
bir alt başlığımız
var
arkadaşlar
eğer
kopyalamada
kullandığımız
hani o değerini
alacağımız
nesne
ifadesi
rvalue
expression'sa
bizim hiçbir şey
yapmamız
gerekmiyor
ama
öyle durumlar
var ki
bir nesne
hayatta
olduğu
olmasına rağmen
bir nesnenin
hayata devam
etmesine rağmen
yani
nesnenin
hayatı
bitmeyecek
elimizde bir
biraz daha
farklı şekilde
ifade edersek
elimizde bir
l-value expression
biçiminde
value kategorisinde
bir sınıf nesnesi
olmasına rağmen
yine de
onun
kaynağını
çalmak
istiyoruz
bunun
yapılacağı
hatta yapılmasının
iyi olduğu
bir sürü
senaryo var
yani bu
çok ütopik
ya da
marjinal
bir senaryo
değil
mesela kafamızda
canlandırılmış
şimdi biz
orijinal
string sınıfından
örneği verelim
değerli arkadaşlarım
diyelim ki
benim
string sınıfı
türünden
bir nesnem var
string
stl
kodu açıklayacağım
merak etmeyin
on bin tane
a karakterinden
oluşan
bir yazıyı
tutuyor
string sınıfının
böyle bir
konstruktörü var
bu konstruktör
hep popüler olarak
feel
konstruktör deniyor
birinci parametre
tane adet
ikinci parametre
hangi karakterden
yani şimdi
str nesnesini
bu konstruktör
hayata getirdiğinde
str'nin tuttuğu
yazı ne
kaveh
on bin tane
a karakteri
anlaşıldı
değil mi
tamam
şimdi ben
yeni bir
string nesnesi
oluştursam
stut string
efendim
sx
olsun
ismi
eşittir
stl
burada
sx için
copy
konstruktör
mı
çağrılır
mu
konstruktör
mı
cevap
copy
konstruktör
peki öyle bir
senaryo olsun ki
barış doğa
oğuzhan
esin
öyle bir
senaryo olsun ki
ben şunu
bilerek
isteyerek
seçeyim
evet
stl'nin
hayatının devam
ettiğini
biliyorum
ama ben
stl'yi
artık
kullanmayacağım
dolayısıyla
sx'in
stl'nin
kaynağını
kopyalamasını
değil
çalmasını
istiyorum
bunu yapmak
mümkün mü
işte
studmovla
bunu yapabilirim
değil mi
çünkü bu
l value
ama
ben
hayata getirecek
nesneyi
bir
r value
expression
yaparsam
şimdi
stl'nin
kaynağını
çaldım
stl'nin
buraya çok dikkatli
izleyelim
üstten
stl'nin
kaynağını
çaldım
arkadaşlar
işte
bu noktadaki
stl'nin
gibi nesnelerin
state'ine
move
from
state
ya da
object
nesneden
bahsediyorsam
deniyor
yani
nesne halen
hayatta
ama
kaynağı
çalınmış
buraya kadar
anladık mı
arkadaşlar
bazı kitaplarda
ya da makalelerde
ya da blog
yazılarında
konu
tamamen yanlış
anlatılmış
o kadar çok
kitap görüyorum ki
asla bunu yapmayın
falan gibi
zırva
olur mu
bunu yapacağımız
tabii ki bu örnekte
ihtiyaç noktası
görülmüyor
ama bunu bilerek
isteyerek
yapacağımız yerler
var mı
var
şimdi
bu durumda
şu soruyu
sormam gerekiyor
peki
herhangi bir problem
olmaması için
böyle durumlarda
neler yapabilirim
yani gerçekten
kaynağını
çaldım
arkadaşlar
birinci ihtimal
birinci seçenek
şu olabilir
artık
stl'yi
hiç kullanmazsınız
yani
stl'nin
kaynağı
çalınmıştır
ve ne zaman
stl'nin
destraktör'ı
çağrılacak olsa
mesela bu
şöyle bir blok
olduğunu düşünelim
buraya geldiğinde
stl'nin
destraktör'ı
çağrılacak
değil mi
stl'nin
destraktör'ının
çağrılması
herhangi bir
soruna yol açacak mı
evet ya da
hayır değil
cevap
hayır
çünkü onun
mu konstraktör'ı
ona göre yazılmış
peki
şimdi burada
çok önemli
bir soru
daha var
ben stl'yi
kullanabilir miyim
yani stl'nin
kaynağını
çaldım ama
stl'yi
kullanabilir miyim
arkadaşlar
aksi yönde
hayır
kesinlikle
undefined
behavior
değil
olsanız
undefined
behavior
diyenler
eğer daha önce
öyle öğrendiyseniz
kesinlikle
yanlış cevap
arkadaşlar
standart
kütüphanenin
türleri
yani
stl'n gibi
ve
üçüncü
parti
kütüphanelerinde
eğer özel bir durum
yoksa
sınıfları
kaynağa çalınmış
nesneler için
tipik olarak
şu garantiyi
veriyor
mesela
string sınıfı
için bu garanti
var
diyor ki
kaynağa çalınmış
bir nesne
bir kere
valid state
de olacak
a
türçe yazacağım
resul anlamadığınız
türkçe terim olursa
tekrar etmemi
isteyin
kaynağı
çılınmış
nesne
arkadaşlar
ne halde
olacak
in a
valid
state
bu ne demek
bir nesnenin
valid state
olması ne demek
geçerli durumda
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
invariantları
korunmuş
olacak
invariant ne demek
onu da açıklayacağım
yani
invariantları
bozulmayacak
b
buraya dikkat
destraktörün
çağrılması
herhangi bir şekilde
bir soruna yol açmayacak
arkadaşlar
nesne
hangi durumda
destraktible
yani kaynağa
çalınmış olması
destraktörünün
çağrılması
durumunda
bir problem
olmayacağı
garantisini de
veriyor
standart
eğer sınıf
doğru bir şekilde
implement edilmiş
burayı anladık mı
ama
arkadaşlar
nesnenin değeri
buraya dikkat
garanti altında
değil
bakın
valid state
olması
başka
nesnenin
değerinin
ne olduğu
başka
mesela
standart
kütüphanenin
string sınıfı
için
biz bir
string nesnesinin
kaynağını
çalsak
ve
string nesnesinin
arkadaşlar
o kaynağa
çalınmış
nesnenin
tuttuğu
yazıyı
bir şekilde
yazdırsak
ve o yazı
fatih yazı
olsa
halen
fatih yazısını
tutuyor
sınıfın
length fonksiyonu
string sınıfı
nesnesinin
tuttuğu yazının
uzunluğunu
döndürüyor
bu durumda
length fonksiyonunun
5 değerini
döndürmesi
garanti altında
mı
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
cevap
evet
garanti altında
valid state
olması
bu
demek
yani
sınıf nesnesinin
üye fonksiyonları
çağrıldığında
herhangi bir şekilde
bir problem
yok
ama
değerinin
ne olduğunu
bilmiyoruz
bunu tıpkı
şuna benzetebilirsiniz
sorularınıza cevap
vereceğim
burası biraz
zorlayıcı
mesela
bir fonksiyonun
parametresi
string türünden
olsaydı
ben size
şöyle bir soru
sorsaydım
buraya çok dikkatli
izleyin
buraya gelen
x'in
değeri
hangi yazı
siz ne cevap
verdiniz
ne bileyim
ben
ne gönderildiyse
o
peki
buraya gelen
stringin
tuttuğu yazı
k vs
length fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
5 değerini döndürür mü
evet
buraya gelen
string nesnesinin
tuttuğu yazı
boş ise
empty string ise
length fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
0 değerini
döndürür mü
kesinlikle
burayı anladık mı
o zaman
buraya geri döneceğiz
kaynağı çalınmış
nesne
in a valid state
geçerli bir değerde
invariantları
tutuyor
invariantlarının
tutması ne demek
mesela
uzunluk değeri
gerçekten
yazının
uzunluk değeri
stringin
tuttuğu yazı
necati yazısı
ise
uzunluğu
stringin
tuttuğu nesne
boş yazı
ise
yazı
boş yazı
ise
uzunluğu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
boş yazı
tutuyorsa
empty fonksiyonu
true döndürecek
gibi
nesnenin
destroy edilmesine
bir problem yok
ama
en önemli
garantiye
bakalım
buraya
dikkat
arkadaşlar
nesneye
yeni bir
değer
atayarak
tekrar
kullanabiliriz
onu
tekrar
kullanabiliriz
işte
standart
kütüphanenin
move from state
teki nesneler
için
verdiği
garanti bu
bir kez daha
tekrar edelim mi
move from state
teki
nesnenin
değerinin
ne olacağı
değerliyiciye
bağlı
ama
nesne
geçerli
bir durumda
yani
o değeri
kullanabilirim
işime
geliyorsa
anlaşıldı
değil mi
o değeri
kullanmak
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir tanımsız
davranış
değil
mesela
nesnenin
tuttuğu
değer
halen
fatih
yazısı
ise
onun
yazının
iki
indekste
karakterinin
arkadaşlar
t
olduğu
garanti
altında
nesneye
yenide
yer atarsak
invariantlarının
durumu ne olur
yine
invariantlar
ingilizcesi
hold eder
yani
invariantlar
yine doğru
durumda olur
yani
bozulmaz
anlaşıldı mı
şimdi
nedense
burayı
genelde kitaplar
yanlış anlatıyor
ve hep
şunu
görüyorum
arkadaşlar
move from state
teki nesneyi
kullanmak
tanımsız
davranış
alakası
böyle bir şey
yok
kim uydurmuşsa
anlaşıldı
değil mi
hatta tam
tersi
şimdi bir örnek
saatte 21.07
olmuş
ara vermeyi
de unutmuşum
ara verdikten
sonra
bir kod örneği
göstereceğim
kod review'larda
beni çok
sık karşıma
çıkıyor
mesela
arkadaşlar
kaynağı
bilerek
isteyerek
çalmanın
yani
nesneyi
hayatta
tutarak
kaynağını
çalmanın
çok tipik
bir örneğini
vereceğim
ama önce
bir ara
verelim
isterseniz
saat 21.08
21.25
de devam
edelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi sorulan
bir soru var
önce ona bir cevap
vereyim
hocam az önceki örnekte
taşıdığımızda
null pointer
ataması yaptık
ya da erişmeye
çalıştığımızda
null pointer
d referans
etmiş
olmaz mıyız
arkadaşlar
ben sadece
kodun bir kısmını
gösterdim
sınıfın
tamamını
implemente
etmedim
ama
standart
kütüphanenin
string sınıfı
gibi
mood
from state
deki
string
nesneleri
için
az önce
bahsettiğim
garantileri
veriyor
olsaydım
sizin dediğiniz
gibi
hiçbir problem
olmayacaktı
ama ben
gerçek bir
implementasyon
yapmadım
ama örneğin
bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekti mi
en azından
kodu
kopyalamadık
sanıyorum
en son haliyle
ama en azından
şunu yaptık
olsan
orada
zaten
vurgu
onun için
yaptım
buraya bakın
dikkat ederseniz
other'ın
emlenini de
sıfır yaptım
yani
bu
move assignment
ya da
move
constructor
çağrıldığında
mood
from state
teki
nesneyi
benim kodum
mp
pointer'ını
null pointer
yaptı
emleni
arkadaşlar
sıfır yaptı
şimdi
ben eğer
diğer fonksiyonları
çağırsaydım
örneğin
empty fonksiyonu
emlen sıfırsa
empty burada
is empty
anlamında
yani boş mu
true değer
dönecekti
yani diğer fonksiyonların
çağrılmasında
herhangi bir problem
oluşmayacaktı
sadece
ne diyor
standart
mood from state
teki nesnenin
diyor
değeri konusunda
garanti vermiyorum
mesela şöyle
olabilir mi
güzel bir soru
şöyle olabilir mi
standart
kütüphanliğin
string sınıfından
bahsediyorum
nesnenin
tuttuğu yazı
Oğuzhan Esin
yazısıydı
onun
kaynağını
çaldım
fakat
o kaynağa
çalınmış
nesnenin
tuttuğu yazıyı
ekrana yazdırdığımda
yine Oğuzhan Esin
yazdırıyor
böyle bir durum
olabilir mi
olabilir
bu durumda
bir yanlışlık
var mı
yok
ama
eğer
gerçekten
örneğin
Oğuzhan Esin
yazısını
yazdırıyorsa
o zaman
length fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
Oğuzhan Esin
yazısının
uzunluğunu
göndürecek
köşeli parantez
fonksiyonuyla
operatör fonksiyonuyla
örneğin yazının
ilk karakterine
eriştiğimde
o karakter
O olmak zorunda
yazının
üçüncü karakterine
eriştiğimde
o karakter
U olmak zorunda
unspecified
valid
but unspecified
value
ama o değer
geçerli olacak
şimdi
eğer herkes
gelmişse
evet
saatte saatte
21-27
olmuş
şimdi ben
bir örnek
kod yazmak istiyorum
bunu gösteren
Necati
Yusuf'un
sorusu
kaynakları
çalan nesne
yok edilirse
mood from state
statüsündeki
olan nesne
etkilenir mi
hayır
onun kaynağını
çalmış olmam
bu ikisi arasında
bir bağlantı
olduğu anlamına
gelmiyor
bunlar yine
bütün atama
kopyalama işlemlerinde
olduğu gibi
yine birbirinden
bağımsız
nesneler
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani kaynağını
çalan nesnede
bir değişiklik
olması
Yusuf Bey'in
sorusunu doğru
anlamışsam
kaynağa
çalınan nesnede
bir değişiklik
olacağı
anlamına
gelmiyor
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
yazacağım
kod
sizin bilmediğiniz
öğeler içeriyor
olacak
yani en azından
bu kursa katılmadan
önce C++
öğrenmediyseniz
dolayısıyla
kodu yazmamı
bekleyin
ve soruyu
sormamı
bekleyin
anlamadığınız
kısımları
herhangi bir şekilde
dikkate almayın
o da açıklayacağım
merak etmeyin
bekleyin
aboneanni
evet
Altyazı M.K.
Burada programçı şunu yapmak istiyor arkadaşlar.
Bir dosyayı, tekst dosyasını açacak.
Dosyadan satır satır okuma yapacak.
Bunu C kodu olarak da yazmayı bildiğinizi varsayıyorum.
Ve dosyadan okuduğu satırları string nesnelerinde tutacak.
Ve bu string nesnelerinde bir dinamik diziye koyacak.
Yani bu kod çalıştığı zaman Svec aslında dinamik dizi, elemanları string olan dinamik dizi ve Svec'in elemanları olan stringler ismi text.txt olan dosyadaki, text dosyasındaki satırları tutuyor.
Buraya kadar yaptığım açıklamayı anladınız mı?
Önce buna kodu anladınız mı diye sormuyorum.
Ne yapıldığı konusunda yaptığım açıklamayı anladınız mı?
Evet en az bir arkadaşım cevap verirse.
Kaveh yes diyor.
Evet herkes anladınız.
Süper.
Ama tabii arkadaşlar kodu detaylı olarak açıklasaydım bir sürü başka konuya gönderme yapacaktım.
Şimdi bu arada şunu da konuşalım.
Buradaki sınıf nesnelerinin tek tek bana gösterir misiniz?
Bu sorunun şu andaki konumuzla alakası yok.
Bir tekrar yapmak amaçlı tahmin.
Mesela IFS bir sınıf nesnesi mi?
Cevap.
Evet.
CRR bir sınıf nesnesi mi?
Tahmin etmenizi istiyorum.
Bilmenizi değil.
Evet.
Svec bir sınıf nesnesi mi?
Sline bir sınıf nesnesi mi?
Evet.
Bakın gerçekten burada gerek Sline, Svec, IFS, CRR bunların hepsi bir arı sınıflar türünden nesneler.
Ama şimdi kodun aslında anlamanızı istediğim kısmı burası.
Arkadaşlar söyleyin bakalım.
Az önce ben pushback fonksiyonunu anlatmıştım.
Amacım vektör sınıfını anlatmak değildi ama ne dedim size pushback'in iki tane overloadu var.
Biri argüman olarak aldığı stringi taşıyarak konteyner'a koyuyor.
Diğeri kopyalayarak konteyner'a koyuyor.
Şimdi kafanızda benim cümlelerime uygun şekilde bir görüntü oluşturmaya çalışın.
Bu öyle bir tekst dosyası ki bu tekst dosyasındaki her bir satır çok uzun.
Beş bin karakter, iki bin karakter, on bin karakter.
Arkadaşlar söyleyin bakalım burada az önce söylediğim overloadlardan arkadaşlar parametresi const string ref olan pushback mi çalışacak yoksa string ref ref olan mı çalışacak?
Hangisi?
Cevap copy const string ref.
Neden?
Çünkü lvalue expression.
O zaman bu kodun şöyle çalıştığını varsayabilir miyiz?
Dosyadan okuduğumuz sline'ı okuduğumuz o okuma işini getline fonksiyonu yapıyor.
Dosyadan file'dan sline'ı okuduğumuz her bir stringin kopyasını çıkartarak konteyner'a koyuyor.
Yani her satır için bir kopyalama yapılıyor.
Mesela ilk okuduğumuz satırda Cengiz Han beş bin karakterlik bir yazı varsa konteyner'ımıza onu koyarken string sınıfının copy constructor'ı mı çağırılacak?
Move constructor'ı mı?
Cevap copy constructor'ı çağırılacak.
Bravo.
Copy constructor'ın çağırılması demek o beş bin karakterlik bellek alanını allocate edecek.
Diğerinden buraya kopyalama yapacak, deep copy yapacak.
Peki şimdi söyleyin eğer sline yani argüman olan ifade sağ taraf değeri olsaydı, rvalue expression olsaydı bu sefer o dosyadan her satıra okuduğunda onu kopyasını çıkartmak yerine taşıma yapacaktı değil mi?
Kesinlikle burayı anlıyor musunuz?
Peki bir dakika ama burada döngünün bir sonraki turuna geçtiğimde ben mood from state'de olan sline'ı kullanmış oluyorum değil mi?
Eğer şimdi o yanlış anlatan arkadaşların dediği doğru olsaydı mood from state'deki sline nesnesini kullanmam tanımsız davranışa yol açsaydı bu kodda undefined behavior olurdu değil mi?
Oysa bu kodda undefined behavior var mı? Yok.
Çünkü standart kütüphanemizin string sınıfı mood from state'deki nesneye yeni bir değer atanmasını, yeni bir değer yüklenmesini mümkün kılıyor değil mi?
Bu garanti veriyor değil mi?
Bu soru size de sorulabilir.
O zaman soruda neyin sorgulandığını anladınız değil mi?
Siz de deneyin bu kodu gösterin.
Bu kodda herhangi bir problem ya da bir eksiklik var mı?
Yorum yapmasını isteyin.
Gerçekten bakın mülakatlara katlanan PPP bunlar da yeni başlayanlar değil.
Arkadaşlar 4-5 senedir belki C++ kodu yazanlar dahi bu koddaki eksik noktayı göremiyorlar.
Ama arada çok ciddi bir performans farkı var.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Oysa nesin?
Hocam bu sınıfların bu garantiyi verdiğine nasıl emin oluruz?
Hepsini böyle kabul ederek yazmamızda bir sakınca olur mu?
Çok çok güzel bir soru.
Çok güzel bir soru.
Bu sınıfların bu garantiyi verdiğini bize standart söylüyor.
C++ standartı söylüyor.
Dolayısıyla yanlış anlaşılmasın.
Mesela 3. parti bir kütüphanedeki bir sınıfında bu garantiyi verdiğinden emin olabilir misiniz?
Hayır.
Ama genelde eğilim şu.
Eğer doğru bir şekilde dokümante edilmişse bunu bildirir.
Bildirmesi lazım.
Yani örneğin move from state'teki nesnenin invalid state'te olduğunu yazması gerekir.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Yani sınıfın uygun şekilde dokümante edilmesi gerekir.
Standart kütüphanenin konteyner sınıfları için bu garanti kesinlikle veriliyor.
Vektör sınıfı için.
String sınıfı için.
Ama bakın verilmeyen bir garantiyi söyleyeyim.
Buraya dikkat.
Verilmeyen bir garantiyi söyleyeyim.
Şimdi burada bir string teslim olsa.
String sınıfı için.
Lütfen bunu genelleştirmeyin.
Verdiğim örnek string sınıfı için.
String str, Oğuzhan Esin ve Fatih Akgül C++ programcıları.
Böyle bir yazı olsun arkadaşlar.
Şimdi şöyle bir kod yazıyorum.
Oto S eşittir move str.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Peki şimdi standart kütüphane standart C++ standartı şunu mu söylüyor?
String boş olmak zorunda.
Böyle bir garanti var mı?
Yok.
String valid state'te olacak.
Hadi bu valid state'in ne olduğunu ben size söyleyeyim arkadaşlar.
Mesela S'in Length'i.
String sınıfının Length ya da Size üye fonksiyonları tutulan yazının uzunluğunu döndürüyor.
S demişim özür dilerim.
String diyecektim.
Yazdıralım.
Arkadaşlar.
String'in Length'i.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Uzunluk kaçmış Oğuzhan?
Sıfır.
Yani benim implementasyonum move from state'teki string destesinin uzunluğunu ne olarak bırakmış?
Cevap vermeye çalışan sıfır.
Peki şimdi soru.
Standart kütüphanenin verdiği garantiyle örneğin şöyle bir fonksiyon çağırsam arkadaşlar.
Evet boş yazı.
İpin doğru kısmına girme garantisi var mı?
Empty fonksiyonu is empty anlamında.
Yani yazı boş bu sorusuna cevap veriyor.
Cevap.
Evet arkadaşlar bu garanti var.
Uzunluğu sıfırsa yazı da boş demektir.
Ya da şu koda bakın.
Şimdi valid state'ten ne anlaşıldığını daha iyi anlıyorsunuz değil mi?
Mesela şöyle bir kod yazsam.
String'in bunları öğreneceğiz.
Arkadaşlar.
String'in S demişim.
STR.
Bravo.
Hatamı arkadaşlar.
Bakınız.
STR.
Sadece izleyin.
Arkadaşlar.
Mesela böyle bir kod yazsam.
Parantezin içinde hiçbir karakter olmayacağı garantisi var mı?
Var.
Anladınız değil mi?
E çünkü STR madem uzunluğu sıfır.
Uzunluğu sıfırsa boş olmak zorunda.
Bu yazı da çıkacak.
Uzunluğu sıfırsa yazıyı yazdırdığımda karakteri olmayan bir boş yazı olacak.
Bakın derliyorum.
Sıfır.
Evet boş yazı dur.
Peki diyelim ki implementasyon çok küçük bir ihtimal ama move from state'teki nesneyi halen bu değerle bırakmış olsaydı o zaman length fonksiyonunu çağırdığımda işte bu yazının uzunluğu kaçsa diyelim ki 58 58 döndürecekti burası false döndürecekti ve yazıyı yazdırdığımda bu yazı yazdırılacaktı.
Şimdi her şey anlaşılıyor mu?
Valid state'ten de kast edildiğini anlıyor musunuz?
Ve bütün bunlardan sonra arkadaşlar devam ediyorum.
Örneğin STR'ye barış doğa yavaş böyle bir atama yapsaydım.
String sınıfını incelerken bütün bu fonksiyonları göreceğiz.
Burada herhangi bir tanımsız davranış olacak mıydı?
Muhammed barış herhangi bir tanımsız davranış olmayacaktı.
Peki programın akışı bu noktaya geldiğinde STR nesnesi için destraktır çağrılacak mı?
Cevap evet.
Destraktırın çağrılması herhangi bir soruna yol açacak mı?
Hayır.
İşte standart kütüphanenin kendi türleri için verdiği garanti move from state'teki nesneler için bu.
Şimdi bütün sınıflar bu garantileri vermek zorunda değil.
Tekrar arkadaşımın güzel sorusuna geri dönecek olursak olsa nesinin.
Bütün sınıflar böyle bir garantiyi vermek zorunda değil.
Ama bu konuda en azından bir belgeleme yapmaları kesinlikle gerekir.
Genelde de onu yapmıyorlar.
Yani işte genelde kötü kod yazdığımız zaman bunlara da dikkat etmiyoruz.
Yoksa şimdi ben hiç bilmediğim bir sınıfın örneğin Ali Ertaş bir sınıf yazıyor olsa,
o sınıfın ben client'i olsam, move from state'teki bir sınıf nesnesini Ali Bey'in yazdığı kullansam,
arkadaşlar onun invariantlarının korunacağı garantisi var mı?
Yok.
Ama bunu dokümante etmesi lazım.
Yani burada gerçekten dokümantasyonun en fazla önem taşıdığı yerlerden biri.
Çünkü başkalarını zor durumda bırakırsınız.
Move from state'teki nesneyi kullanarak başını derde sokabilir.
Ya da özel bir biçimde kullanarak başını derde sokabilir.
Peki buraya kadar geldik.
Gayet güzel.
Bir soru daha.
Peki Ölhan bu garantiyi vermeyen X bir klası Unique PTR ile sarmalarsak,
yine garantiyi göz önüne almakta bir sakınca olur mu?
Arkadaşlar şimdi bu soruya cevap vermeyeyim.
Çünkü diğer arkadaşları demotive eder.
Çok uzun konuşmam gerekiyor.
Şimdi Unique PTR nedir?
Ne işe yarar?
O kadar çok konudan bahsetmem gerekiyor ki o soruya tam bir cevap verebilmem için.
O yüzden şimdilik cevap vermeyeyim olur mu?
Ama ileride mutlaka cevap veririm.
Peki şimdi çok dikkatli izleyelim arkadaşlar.
Sınıfların copy constructörü ya da copy assignment'ı varsa yani sınıf nesnelerinin kopyalanmasında herhangi bir problem yoksa böyle sınıflara copyable sınıflar diyebilirsiniz.
Yani kopyalanabilir.
Yani kopyalanmasında herhangi bir engel yok.
Ama bazı durumlarda biz sınıfların, sınıf nesnelerinin kopyalanmasını engellemek istiyoruz.
Yani kopyalama semantiğini sınıfa vermemek istiyoruz.
Nedeni kopyalamanın o sınıf için anlamlı bir yapı oluşturmaması.
Yani kopyalamanın semantik karşılığının olmaması arkadaşlar.
Yani öyle sınıflar var ki problem domenindeki temsil ettikleri varlık nedeniyle temsil ettikleri kavram için zaten kopyalama ya bir anlam taşımıyor ya saçma ya problemli.
Mesela bir dosyayı kontrol eden sınıf nesnesini düşünelim.
Az önceki kodda öyle bir sınıf nesnesi vardı.
İşte buradaki biraz daha geri gideyim.
Mülakat sorsu demiştim ya.
İFS.
Arkadaşlar şimdi burada dosya işlemlerinin nasıl yapıldığı hakkında biraz fikir sahibiyseniz.
Gerçekten bu nesnenin bir kopyasının çıkartılmasının anlamsız olduğunu.
Yani böyle bir durumun zaten mantıksal olarak bir karşılığının olmadığını anlarsınız.
İşte böyle sınıflarda tipik olarak sınıf kopyalamaya karşı kapatılıyor.
Yani kopyalama yanlış kötü bir durum oluşturmak yerine kopyalama sentaks hatası haline getiriliyor.
Bunu yapmanın da yolu tahmin edebildiğiniz gibi sınıfın kopyalayan özel fonksiyonlarını delete etmek.
Yani örneğin class match.
Ben match sınıfı türünden nesnelerin kopyalanmasını istemiyorsam.
Bakın bunun birden fazla nedeni olabilir.
Ama en tipik nedeni match sınıfı problem domeninde neyi temsil ediyorsa onun kopyalanmasının bir anlamının olmaması.
Mesela arkadaşlar bir mutex'in kopyalanması anlamlı değil ya da doğru değil.
Arkadaşlar o zaman match sınıfını kopyalamaya karşı kapatmak için ne yapacağım?
Sınıfın copy konstruktörünü ve copy assignment'ını delete edeceğim.
Diğer kodları göstermiyorum.
Yani şöyle bir durum söz konusu olduğunu düşünün.
Match const match ref eşittir delete.
Match ref operatör atama const match ref eşittir delete.
13. satırdaki bildirim sınıfın copy konstruktörünü delete bildirimi ve 14. satırdaki bildirim sınıfın arkadaşlar copy assignment'ının delete edilme bildirimi.
Ve sınıfa bir default konstruktörü bildirelim ve bakın kodlara şimdi.
Match türünden x, match türünden y, x.
kopyalamanın söz konusu olduğu herhangi bir yerde doğrudan copy konstruktörün çağrılması gerekiyor.
Ama copy konstruktörü delete edildiği için derli içi delete edilmiş fonksiyonla yapılan çağrı ifadesi sentaks hatası oluşturuyor değil mi?
Bakın sentaks hatası olarak bu sözel yapıyı kullandı.
Ama sadece bu durumda değil.
Atama durumunda da örneğin match x, y, x eşittir y.
Bu sefer de dilim kurallarına göre copy assignment fonksiyonunun çağrılması gerekiyor.
Copy assignment fonksiyonunun çağrılması da copy assignment fonksiyonu delete edildiği için sentaks hatası oluşturuyor.
Böyle sınıflardan bahsederken yani kopyalamaya karşı kapatılmış sınıflardan bahsederken onlara non-copyable diyoruz arkadaşlar.
Non-copyable sınıflar.
Mesela standart lütfhanede belirli sınıflar non-copyable.
Mesela arkadaşlar az önceki örneklerden biri izleyin.
Bakın ismi OFS olan bir sınıf nesnesi var.
Oto x eşittir OFS.
Arkadaşlar bakın derleyici nasıl bir sentaks hatası verdi?
Yine delete edilmiş bir fonksiyona yapılan çağrının sentaks hatası olduğunu söyledi.
Neden? Çünkü ileride öğreneceğimiz bu standart kütübhanemizin Offstream isimli sınıfı, bu isimde zaten bir türeş ismi Type Alias, kopyalamaya karşı kapatılmış.
Fakat öyle sınıflar var ki bu sınıfların, bu sınıflar türünden nesnelerin kopyalanması istenmiyor ama taşıma semantiğine açık olması isteniyor.
Yani kopyalaması yasak fakat taşıması serbest.
Mesela az önce arkadaşımız sorusunda, Oğuzhan Bey'in sorusunda bahsettiği ya da adı geçen Unique PTR isimli bir sınıf var.
Bir Smart Pointer sınıfı.
İleride çok ayrıntılı göreceğiz.
Mesela bu sınıf kopyalamaya karşı kapatılmış, İngilizcesiyle non-copyable ama taşımaya açık, but movable arkadaşlar.
Evet, böyle sınıflar için ister non-copyable, but movable gibi uzun bir ifade kullanabilirsiniz.
Ama daha çok kullanılan pratik terim move-only class.
Popülerde.
Move-only class derken kast edilen ne?
Doğrudan az önce söylediğim.
Yani kopyalaması yok fakat taşınması var.
Mesela işte az önceki stream sınıfları genelde bunlar move-only sınıflar.
Ya da stud-thread sınıfı örneğin kopyalamaya karşı kapatılmış ama taşımaya karşı açık bir sınıf.
Şimdi geldik hem konunun hem de dersin en zor kısmına.
Eğer şimdiye kadar zorlanmadıysanız şimdi biraz zorlanacaksınız.
Ve şunu da söyleyeyim bir ezber yükü de gelecek.
Arkadaşlar sınıfların özel üye fonksiyonları söz konusu olduğunda programcıların öğrenmekte zorluk çektiği yerlerden biri de biraz öğrenme yükü var.
Derleyicinin hangi durumlarda sınıfların hangi special member function'ını implicitly declare edeceği.
Yani örneğin size ben bir sınıf göstersem bu sınıfın move konstruktörü var mı, move assignment'ı var mı, copy konstruktörü var mı, copy assignment'ı var mı?
Bunların cevabını biliyor olmanız gerekiyor.
Dilin burada neleri var?
Arkadaşlar kuralları var.
Burada biraz sabırlı olmanızı başta isteyeceğim.
Ondan sonra yavaş yavaş anlatacağım.
Belirli bir noktadan sonra anlattıklarımı bir tablo olarak ifade edeceğim.
Şimdi önce şunu anlamanız gerekiyor.
Dilin kuralları hangi durumda derleyicinin hangi üye fonksiyonu arkadaşlar implicitli yani örtülü olarak declare ettiğini ve default ettiğini dilin kuralları beliriyor.
Yani bu derleyiciye bağlı bir durum değil.
Yani implementation defined bir durum değil.
Yani şöyle bir şey olamaz.
Aynı sınıf kodunu Ali Ertaş kendi derleyicisinde derliyor.
Sınıfın move konstruktörü var.
Ama Cengiz Han ayrı bir derleyici de derliyor.
Orada move konstruktörü yok.
Böyle bir senaryo olamaz.
Dilin kuralları net olarak hangi durumda arkadaşlar sınıfın hangi özel üye fonksiyonunun,
special member function'ın derleyici tarafından bildirildiğini doğrudan belirlemiş.
O kuralları öğrenmemiz gerekiyor.
Hemen de öğreniyoruz.
Atla deve değil.
Biraz belki yoracak.
Ama sonunda feraha kavuşacağız.
Göster.
My class herhangi bir sınıf olsun.
Beni izliyorsunuz.
Eğer siz sınıfınız için hiçbir konstruktörü bildirmezseniz,
yani hiçbir konstruktörü yok şu durumda, öyle değil mi?
Derleyici özel üye fonksiyonların hiçbirinin bildirilmediğini görüyorsunuz.
Derleyici bu durumda bütün özel üye fonksiyonları default ediyor.
Bu şu demek, sınıfın böyle yazılması demek, aslında sınıfın şöyle olması demek.
Tek tek gösteriyorum, bakınız.
Yorum satırıyla ya da altına yazayım, yukarıya yorum satırını alırız.
Ya da underscore koyayım olur mu?
Aynı sınıftan bahsettiğim vurgulamak için yardımcı araç altını çizmesin.
Sınıfın default konstruktörü var mı?
Var.
Sınıfın default konstruktörü derleyici tarafından mı yazıldı?
Evet.
Sınıfın topik konstruktörü var mı?
Var.
Burada biraz sabırlı olmanızı isteyeceğim.
Sıkılabilirsiniz ama mutlaka iyi öğrenmemiz gerekiyor.
Evet.
Yine derleyici tarafından mı yazıldı?
Yanlış anlaşılmasın.
Size göstermek için böyle yazıyorum arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar, evet.
MyClass, const MyClass, rev eşittir.
Default.
Bu, copy konstruktör.
Devam edelim.
Pardon, burada underscore'u kullanmadığım için.
Şöyle yapalım, daha pratik olsun.
Şuna underscore yapayım.
Evet.
Ve buradaki underscore'u sileyim.
şimdi oldu.
Bu da derleyici tarafından yazılıyor.
Evet.
Moe konstruktör.
Yes.
Hatta yorum satırına da niye alıyorum ki?
Öyle göstereyim.
Copy assignment.
Yes.
Lütfen her bir durumu doğru anladığınızdan emin olunuz.
Tekrar bakalım.
Sınıfı böyle tanımlamak, bu fonksiyonların derleyici tarafından örtülü olarak bildirilmesi ve tanımının yapılması anlamına geliyor.
Yani 6 özel üye fonksiyonunun 6'sı da var.
Takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Hadi bunu şöyle sonuna da yorum satırı koyalım.
ve arkadaşlar notlar dosyamıza geri dönebilmek için koyalım.
Şimdi ikinci senaryo.
Eğer sınıfı special member function olmayan bir konstruktör koyarsanız, takip edebiliyor musunuz?
Sadece ve sadece şu olmuyor.
Yani default konstruktör olmuyor.
Yani sınıfı böyle tanımlamanız demek, sınıfı aşağıdaki biçimde tanımlamanız demek.
Arkadaşlar buradan şu kuralı da tekrar etmiş oluyoruz.
Sınıfı herhangi bir konstruktör'ı special member function olsun ya da olmasın, user dikler yaptığınız zaman derleyici default konstruktör'ı artık indisip de dikler etmiyor.
Yani bu sınıfın nesi yok arkadaşlar?
Default konstruktör'ı yok.
Peki destruktör, copy konstruktör, move konstruktör, copy assignment, move assignment bunlar var mı?
Var. Burada anlamadığımız bir şey var mı?
Süper. Devam.
Eğer sınıfa default konstruktör bildirirseniz, takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Yani default konstruktör user dikler.
Bu durumda yine sınıfın diğer bütün özel üye fonksiyonları derleyici tarafından default ediliyor.
Yani böyle olması demek, böyle olması demek, böyle olması demek.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Çağrı, alertaş, cengiz an anlamadığımız ya da itiraz etmek istediğimiz bir yer var mı?
Evet, o zaman bunu da geçtik.
Eğer sınıfa destruktör bildirirseniz, takip edin.
destruktör'ı user dikler yapmış olursunuz ama diğer arkadaşlar, özel üye fonksiyonların derleyici tarafından yazılmasında herhangi bir şekilde bir engel yok.
Ama burada bir durmamız gerekiyor.
Bakın bakın, çok dikkatli izleyin.
Tekrar ediyorum.
Sınıfa destruktör bildirirseniz arkadaşlar, şunları sileyim.
Durum şu.
Burası epey kritik.
Bir, arkadaşlar destruktör bildirdiğiniz zaman derleyici sınıfın move memberlarını default etmiyor.
Yani move memberlar yok.
Burayı anladık mı?
Bu birinci sonuç.
İkincisi, arkadaşlar, derleyici default constructor'ı default ediyor.
Copy constructor'ı ve copy assignment'ı yine default ediyor.
Ama bu durum son derece tehlikeli.
Asla asla böyle bir duruma yol açmamanız gerekiyor.
Ve standarda göre bu deprecated ilan edildi.
Yani derleyicinin siz bir destruktör bildirdiğiniz zaman sınıfın copy constructor'ını ve copy assignment'ını default etmesi son derece tehlikeli.
Asla buna başvurmayın.
Ve deprecated.
Yani deprecated olması ne demek?
Gelecekteki bir standartta bu tamamen sentaks hatası yapılabilir.
Buradan çıkan sonuca dikkat.
Hatta şöyle dikkat başlığıyla yazayım.
Dikkat.
Bu durumda sınıfın move memberları yok.
Cengiz Han yine sorunuza isterseniz daha sonra cevap vereyim olur mu?
Yani soru güzel.
Ama buradan kopmayalım.
Evet.
Sorunuzu not ettim.
Şimdi burayı herkes anladı mı?
Çünkü burası bir hayli kritik.
Evet.
Bir kez daha tekrar ediyorum o yüzden.
Sınıfa destruktör bildirirseniz default constructor var.
Destruktör user declared.
Copy constructor ve copy assignment derleyici tarafından yazılıyor.
Ama bu son derece problemli bir durum ve deprecated.
Herkes anladı mı?
Bir şeye daha dikkat etmenizi istiyorum.
Tekrar yazdım buraya zaten.
Dikkat.
Bu durumda sınıfın move memberları yok.
Yani bu sınıfın move constructorı yok.
Delete edilmiş değil.
Move constructorı yok.
Move assignment'ı yok.
Hani sınıfların özel üye fonksiyonları üç durumda olabiliyordu değil mi?
User declared, implicitly declared, bir de not declared.
Şu anda bu sınıfın move memberları not declared.
Yani yoklar.
Olmamasıyla delete edilmesi farklı şeyler.
Bunu da yazdık.
Şimdi nedeni değil.
Önce kuralı öğrenelim.
Dilin kurallarını öğreniyoruz.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Tekrar söylüyorum.
Şimdi eğer soru şuysa Resul neden böyle?
Valla doğrusunu isterseniz.
Zamanında belki sentaks hatası yapılsaydı.
Eski kodlar kırılırdı.
Eski geçmiş kodların legalitesini korumak için.
Destructor'ın bildirilmesi durumunda.
Arkadaşlar.
Copy constructor'ın ve copy assignment'ın derleyici tarafından yazılmasına halen izin veriliyor.
Evet.
Devam.
Eğer.
Şimdi burası bundan sonrası biraz daha zor.
Peki.
Copy constructor bildirilmişse.
My class.
Cons.
Ref.
Yanına da yazılan copy constructor.
Buraya özellikle dikkat.
Ve tahmin etmenizi isteyeceğim.
Evet.
Bir.
Bilenler söylesin.
Bilmeyenler tahmin etsin.
Sınıfın default constructor'ı var mı?
Cevap.
Hayır.
Yok.
Bravo.
Çünkü bir constructor yazdığım anda derleyici default constructor yazmıyor.
Bakın.
Delete edilmiş değil.
Yok.
Sınıfın destructor'ı var mı?
Cevap.
Var.
Sınıfın copy constructor'ı zaten user declared.
Copy assignment'ı cevap tahmin edin.
Yine var.
Yine default ediliyor.
Maalesef.
Moe constructor'ı var mı?
Tahmin edin.
Cevap.
Yok.
Moe assignment'ı var mı?
Cevap.
Yok.
Dolayısıyla bakın.
Sınıfa eğer bir copy constructor bildirirseniz.
Bir kez daha üstünden geçelim mi?
Sınıfa bir copy constructor bildirirseniz.
Destructor default ediliyor.
Default constructor yok.
Ve copy assignment default ediliyor.
Moe constructor ve move assignment yok.
Şimdi copy constructor'ı yazdık.
Devam.
Copy assignment.
Arkadaşlar ben size kuralları anlatıyorum.
Bunların ne işe yarayacağı, neden böyle yapıldığını anlatmıyorum ki.
Bunların doğru ya da yanlış olduğunu da söylemiyorum ki olsan.
Önce kuralları öğreneceğiz.
Yani sanki ben size şöyle bir şey söylemişim gibi.
Böyle bir sınıf oluşturun.
Keyfinize bakın.
Afiyetle kullanın.
Böyle bir şey demedim ki.
Anlatabiliyor muyum?
Önemli olan şimdi burada hangi durumda derleyicinin hangi fonksiyonları örtülü olarak
implicit dedikler ettiğini öğrenmek.
Yoksa benim ağzımdan şöyle bir cümle çıkmadı ki.
Bir sınıfın copy constructor'ını bildirin ama diğer özel üye fonksiyonlarını bildirmeyin.
Böyle bir şey söylemedim.
Peki.
Gelelim atama operatör fonksiyonuna.
Kopyalayan atama operatör fonksiyonuna.
Copy assignment.
Ve yine tahminde bulunmaya çalışalım.
Arkadaşlar.
Soru 1.
Default constructor var mı?
Devam var.
Soru 2.
Destructor var mı?
Var.
Soru 3.
Copy constructor var mı?
Cevap var.
Soru mu constructor var mı?
Tahmin edin.
Cevap yok.
Move assignment var mı?
O zaman bir kez daha tekrar edelim.
Sınıfa kopyalayan atama operatör fonksiyonuna yazarsanız.
Bu durumda arkadaşlar default constructor derleyici tarafından default edilecek.
Destructor default edilecek.
Copy constructor default edilecek.
Tabii şunu da eklemeliyiz.
Copy assignment user declared.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Devam.
Move memberlar yok.
Şimdi.
Aman dikkat.
Sınıfa move constructor yazarsanız.
My class.
Arkadaşlar.
Tabii bu arada bunların hep public olduğunu düşünüyoruz.
Yani şuraya public sözcüğünü yazmamışım.
Hep yazdığımı düşünün.
Bunun gelişim kontrolüyle şimdilik bir alakası yok.
Tamam.
Şimdi soru.
Sınıfa move constructor'ı user declared yapıyorum.
Yine tahminlerinizi alacağım.
Bakalım doğru tahmini.
Bilenler değil tahmin edenler söylesin.
Evet.
Default constructor'ı var mı?
Cevap yok.
Çünkü bu bir constructor.
Neydi kural?
Bir tane constructor bildirirseniz derleyici default constructor'ı arkadaşlar bildirmez.
O zaman default constructor yok.
Devam ediyorum.
Destructor var mı?
Cevap var.
Destructor.
Default edilmiş.
Copy constructor var mı?
İşte burada cevabınız yanlış.
Yani tahmininiz yanlış.
Copy constructor var ama delete edilmiş.
Yani sınıfa.
Yani sınıfa move constructor'ı bildirirseniz derleyici copy constructor'ı delete ediyor.
Yani şöyle myclass arkadaşlar const const myclass ref eşittir delete.
derleyici böyle bir kod ekliyor.
Böyle bir kod ekliyor.
Copy assignment var mı?
Cevap bravo.
Bu sefer tahmini doğru.
Var ama delete edilmiş.
Myclass ref.
Operatör.
Atama const myclass ref eşittir delete.
E zaten move constructor.
User declared.
Move assignment var mı?
Cevap.
Move assignment yok.
Not declared.
Yani böyle bravo.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Ve son olarak
daha sonra ben size bunu bir tablo halinde kendi oluşturduğum tablo halinde vereceğim.
Bir katkın bakın ezberleyene kadar.
Peki move assignment yazarsam.
Myclass ref.
Operatör atama.
Myclass ref ref.
Move assignment.
Yine bu sefer tahminlerinin hepsinin doğru olacağını düşünüyorum.
Bekliyorum.
Default constructor.
Var.
Destructor.
Cevap var.
Devam.
Copy constructor.
Elited.
Bravo.
Move constructor.
Yok.
Evet.
Move assignment.
User declared.
Arkadaşlar şimdi kafanız karışmış olabilir.
Gayet normal.
Ben size toplu sonuçları vereceğim şimdi.
Yani toplu sonuçlar derken neyi kastediyorum?
Bütün bu söylediklerimin hem özeti hem de buradaki kritik noktalar.
Şimdi söylediklerimi anladığınızı onaylayın olur mu arkadaşlar?
Anladığınızı onaylayın.
Çünkü her bir cümle önemli.
Bir kere izleyin.
Bir sınıfa herhangi bir konstruktör bildirirsek, default konstruktör olmayan,
herhangi bir konstruktör bildirirsek derleyici,
default konstruktörü bildirmez.
Yani not declared durumuna düşer.
Bunda açık değil mi?
Örneklerin hepsinde arkadaşlar gördük.
Anlamayan var mı?
Evet.
Devam.
İki.
Bir sınıfın her zaman destraktörü vardır.
Burası önemli.
Yani destraktör, hocam son durumda copy assignment delete olması gerekmez miydi?
Delete yazmadın mı?
MyClass, const MyClass yazmamışım onu.
Haklısınız.
Niye yazmadım?
MyClass, ref.
Yazdım zannettim.
Operatör atama.
Onu yazmamışım gerçekten.
Haklısınız.
Operatör atama.
const, onu atlamışım.
MyClass, ref.
Eşittir delete.
Emrecan, teşekkür ederim.
Bunu yazmayı unutmuşum.
Tamam.
Şimdi buraya geri dönüyorum.
Bir sınıfın her zaman destraktörü vardır.
Yani destraktörün olmadığı bir senaryo.
Destraktörü siz bildirirseniz user declared.
Sizin bildirmediğiniz bütün durumlarda arkadaşlar implicit dedikleriz.
Bunda anlaştık mı?
Tamam.
Şimdi buraya dikkat.
bir sınıfın her zaman destraktörü.
Bir sınıfa.
Eskiden büyük üçlü denilen.
Denilen.
Neydi o büyük üçlü eskiden?
Destraktör.
Copy.
Asignment ki o zaman ismi böyle değildi.
Constructor.
Buraya dikkat.
Bunlardan hangisini bildirirseniz bildirin.
Move memberlar not declared olur.
Bunlardan herhangi birini bildirmezseniz arkadaşlar.
Move memberlar.
Move member ne demek?
Move member deyince move constructor, move assignment.
Copy members deyince copy constructor, copy assignment.
Anlaşılıyor.
Bunlardan herhangi birini bildirirseniz bildirmezseniz demişim.
Bildirirseniz derleyici move memberları bildirmez.
Yani bu durumda sınıfın move memberları yoktur.
Bakın delete edilmiş değil.
Move memberları yoktur.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Devam.
Bir sınıfa move memberlardan birini bildirirseniz.
İster move constructor olsun, ister move assignment olsun, derleyici copy memberları ne yapar?
Söyleyin.
Derleyici copy memberları delete eder.
Bravo.
Bu da çok önemli bir kural.
Move memberları yazarsanız copy memberları delete eder.
Mesela demin arkadaşlarından biri böyle böyle yaparsak ne olur falan demişti.
Ben dedim ki onu incelemiyoruz daha, onu da konuşuruz.
Sadece kuralları inceliyoruz.
Ama mesela arkadaşımın sorusuna uygun bir durum.
Çok dikkatli izleyin.
Şimdi şöyle bir sınıf oluştursam.
Class, my class.
Public.
My class, my class.
Refref.
My class.
Ref.
Operatör atama.
My class.
Refref.
Soruyu önce anlamaya çalışın.
Sadece sınıf bu kadar.
Bu sınıf movable but not copyable.
Yani not copyable but movable.
Ya da diğer ismiyle move only class'tır diyebilir miyim?
Evet ya da hayır diyeyim.
Bu sınıf move only class mıdır değil midir?
Cevap evet.
Neden evet?
Çünkü move memberları bildirdiğim için zaten copy memberlar delete olduğu için.
Yani böyle yazmakla gidip de buraya bunlar için delete bildirimi yapmanın bir farkı yok.
Anladınız değil mi?
Zaten derleyici bunları delete ediyor.
Bakın tekrar söylüyorum arkadaşlar.
Düzelteyim ki hata olmasın.
Tekrar söylüyorum.
Sınıfı böyle oluşturmanızla.
Şuradaki referans deklaratörü bitmiş.
Tamam.
Böyle yazmanızla.
Bu delete bildirimlerini hiç yapmamanız arasında bir fark yok.
Çünkü move memberlardan birini bildirirseniz dahi derleyici ne yapıyor?
Copy memberları delete ediyor.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Diğer taraftan move memberlardan birini bildirirseniz sadece.
Mesela sadece move constructor bildirdiniz.
Move assignment'ın durumu ne?
Sadece move constructor bildirdiniz.
Bakalım hatırlıyor musunuz?
Move assignment'ın durumu ne?
Cevap not declared.
Bravo.
Ya da tam tersi move assignment bildirdiniz.
Arkadaşlar.
Efendim move constructor'ın durumu ne?
Cevap not declared.
Bakın şimdi sizinle de paylaşacağım.
Kaynaşacağım.
Burayı boşaltayım.
Ve oluşturduğum tabloyu buraya koyayım.
Hiç unutmamamız gereken bundan sonra bir tablo.
Şimdi belki başlangıçta hemen kafanızda canlandıramayabilirsiniz.
Ama az önce anlattıklarımın toplu sonucu bu.
Ne demek?
Şimdi bakalım.
Eğer hiçbir constructor bildirmezsem default constructor, distracter, copy constructor, copy assignment, move constructor, move assignment hepsini derleyici bildiriyor.
Anlamadığımız bir yer olduğunu da söyleyin.
Ya da olur da ben yanlış bir şey yazmışımdır.
Ayıp olur diye söylememezlik yapmayın.
Arkadaşlar.
Devam.
Eğer tablonun anlamını kavradınız değil mi?
Eğer herhangi bir şey bildirmezsem hepsi bildiriliyor.
Eğer herhangi bir constructor bildirirsem yani special member function olmayan constructor bildirirsem default constructor not declared öbürlerinin hepsi var.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Default constructor bildirirsem arkadaşlar buraya dikkat destracter user declared ama move memberler not declared default constructor defaulted ama copy constructor ve copy assignment defaulted.
Neden bunu farklı renkte yazdım?
Bende renk körlüğü var ama kırmızı olduğunu düşünün.
Çünkü bu istenmeyen bir durum.
Yani böyle bir kod yazmışsanız arkadaşlar hem deprecated açık kırmızıymış bu ara ben kırmızı yanlış söylememişim.
Renklerin çoğunu algılayamıyorum çünkü.
Evet.
Diyor ki Yusuf onların açacağı tehlikeli durumları konuşacak mıyız?
Biz aslında konuştuk bile hatırlarsanız neden copy constructor'ı yazmamız gerekir?
Neden copy assignment'ı yazmamız gerekir?
Aslında açıklaması orada ama Yusuf isterseniz oraya tekrar döneriz bir sonraki derste.
Evet.
Bakınız lütfen mouse'u takip edin.
Destructor, copy constructor, copy assignment hangisini bildirirseniz bildirin.
Move memberler not declared.
Görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Copy constructor bildirirsek o da bir constructor olduğu için default constructor not declared.
Copy assignment defaulted ama çok tehlikeli.
Tehlikeli yine arkadaşlar neden tehlikeli?
Yusuf'un sorusuna da geri dönelim.
Şimdi bakın siz copy constructor yazıyorsanız demek ki onu yazmanız için bir neden var.
Öyle değil mi?
Muhtemelen bir handle var.
Bu durumda copy assignment'ın da onunla aynı mantıkta oluşturulması gerekiyor.
Ama copy assignment'ı derleyici öyle yazmıyor ki.
Evet ve yine move memberler not declared.
Takip edebildik mi?
Copy assignment.
Bu durumda da copy constructor defaulted.
Kırmızı olanlar ya da açık kırmızı olanlar Yusuf'un dediği gibi hem deprecated olanlar hem de yapmanız sakıncalı olan durumlar.
Evet.
Move constructor ya da move assignment'ı bildirirsem buraya dikkat.
Copy memberların delete edildiğini görüyorsunuz.
Move constructor'ı bildirirsem move assignment'ın not declared olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Move assignment'ı bildirirsem move constructor'ın not declared olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Move constructor'ı bildirirsem default constructor'ın not declared olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Aslında bir iki kere bakınca arkadaşlar tabloyu ezberlemeniz mümkün.
Zaten genel mantığı da kavradığınız için ben ciddi bir zorluk çıkacağını düşünmüyorum.
Ama yine de burada itiraz ettiğiniz ya da anlamadığınız herhangi bir nokta varsa onu sorabilirsiniz.
Evet.
Zaten kritik noktaları gösterdim.
Bakın destructor her zaman ya defaulted user declared olmadığı sürece.
Yani destructor'ın olmaması diye bir senaryo söz konusu değil.
Move constructor'lar sınıfa destructor, copy constructor ya da copy assignment bildirirseniz not declared.
Ama sınıfa move member'ları bildirirseniz copy member'lar not declared değil.
Copy member'lar deleted.
Sınıfa bir constructor bildirirseniz ister special member function olan arkadaşlar constructor'lardan biri ister parametreli herhangi bir constructor olsun.
Bu durumda default constructor not declared.
Bakın default constructor'ın not declared olduğu durumlara bakın.
Default constructor'ın not declared olduğu arkadaşlar herhangi bir constructor'ı bildirirsem, copy constructor'ı bildirirsem, move constructor'ı bildirirsem.
Tablo bu kadar açık.
Şimdi buraya kadar biraz yüksek tempoyla geldik.
Anlamadığınız yerler olursa sorun dedim.
Ben son beş dakikayı bundan sonraki konu başlıklarının neler olduğunu açıklamakla geçireceğim.
Yani yeni bir konuya geçmeyeceğim arkadaşlar.
Şimdi bundan sonra göreceğimiz konu başlıkları şunlar.
Bunlar bir kısmı küçük alt başlıklar, bir kısmı önemli alt başlıklar.
Geçen derslerden bir tanesine bir arkadaşım söylemişti.
Ben onu henüz görmedik dedim.
Sanıyorum Cengiz Han arkadaşımdı.
Modern C++'da dile eklenen delegating constructor dediğimiz bir yapı var.
Eski C++'da yoktu.
Yılmaz Çağrı Yüksel.
Açık kırmızıların sorunu yani deprecated senaryolar runtime sorunu yaratacak.
Deleted veya not declared fonksiyonlara erişim istenirse compile time error alacağız.
Doğru mudur?
Şimdi soruyu tam olarak anlamamış olabilir mi?
İki tane ayrı soru mu var?
Deprecated senaryolar runtime sorunu yaratacak.
Yani onun compile time ile alakası yok.
Buraya geri dönelim arkadaşımın sorusunu anlamaya çalışayım.
Mesela bir sınıfa destructor bildirirseniz arkadaşlar,
destructor'ı user declared yaparsanız
ama copy constructor ve copy assignment'ın derleyici tarafından default edilmesini sağlarsanız
bu compile time'a yönelik bir hata değil.
Bu run time'a yönelik bir hata.
Yani bu sınıf nesneleri kopyalandığı zaman copy constructor ya da copy assignment yoluyla
%99.99 derleyicinin yazacağı arkadaşlar copy constructor ve copy assignment sizin işinizi görmeyecek, problem yaratacak.
Eğer bu anlamda söylediyseniz Yılmaz çağrı söylediğiniz şüphesiz doğru.
Ama ikinci soruya ayrı bir soru olarak, bravo ben doğru anlamışım, ikinci soruya ayrı bir soru olarak soruyorsanız
not declare fonksiyonla çağrı yapılması durumu bu runtime ile alakalı değil.
Bu syntax hatası arkadaşlar.
Mesela arkadaşımın sorusunu biraz canlı hale getirelim.
İzleyin bakın canlı hale getirelim.
Hatta şu anda da güzel bir örnek var.
Soru.
My class.
Me.
Sadece sorularıma cevap verin her bir soruya.
Neden sentatat hastan?
Cevap.
Arkadaşlar default constructor yok.
Default bir constructor yok demeyin.
Default constructor yok.
Çünkü constructor yok derseniz aha bu ne derim?
Bu da bir constructor.
Anladım.
Tamam.
Bunun peki.
My class.
Şimdi default constructor var.
M1.
M2.
M1 eşit M2.
Geçerlemediği mi?
Error mü legal mi?
Cevap.
Error.
Neden error?
Çünkü bir move member'ı bildirdiğim için copy member'lar delete edilmiş durumda.
Dolayısıyla derleyici delete edilmiş copy assignment'a çağrı yaptığım, çağrı yapmam nedeniyle sentaks hatası verecek.
Devam ediyorum.
M1 eşittir.
Stood move.
Stood move make'i.
Bu legal mi?
Cevap geçerli.
Çünkü burada eşittir'in sağ tarafındaki ifade r value expression olduğu için move assignment fonksiyonu çağrılacak.
Arkadaşlar çok tipik yapılan bir hata mülakatlarda da soruyorlar ama cevabını bir dahaki derse bırakacağım.
Bakın şimdi copy member'ları delete etmek istenebilir, gerekebilir, son derece doğal.
Yani sınıfın ne olduğuna bağlı olarak non-copyable bir sınıf oluşturmak isteyebilirsiniz.
Ama move member'ları asla delete etmeyin.
Yani hiçbir nedenle bir move member'ın delete edilmesinin size sağlayacağı ekstra bir fayda yok.
Hadi bunu da not alarak alın.
Ben bazen görüyorum.
Mesela move constructor ya da move assignment'ı delete etmiş.
Söyleyin bakalım move member'ları delete ederseniz bunun olası ilk kötü sonucu ne olur?
Move member'ları delete ederseniz bunun olası kötü sonucu ne olur?
Arkadaşlar cevap arkadaşlar copy'e fallback olmaz.
Yani normalde move member olmasaydı copy'e fallback olacaktı değil mi?
Ama move member'ı delete ederseniz move gereken yerde sentaks hatası olur.
Ne demek istediğimi herkes anladı mı?
Yani şöyle bir sınıf olsaydı.
Bak dedi açmayalım.
Şöyle bir sınıf olsaydı arkadaşlar copy constructor'ı var.
Efendim copy assignment'ı var.
Evet.
Ama move member ya da member'lar delete edilmiş.
Şimdi bunun bir mantığı var mı?
Olabilir mi?
Hayır.
Neden?
Çünkü bu durumda taşıma gereken yerde taşıma olmadığı için biz kopyalamaya fallback olmasını istiyoruz.
Ama fallback olma sentaks hatası olur.
İsterseniz bakın şimdi.
My class default constructor arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar sırasını düzeltelim.
Evet.
Const my class ref.
My class ref ref.
Evet.
My class.
Yanlış yazarsam söyleyenin hızlı gidiyorum çünkü.
My class ref ref.
Eşittir.
Delete.
Şimdi programcı ne yapmış?
Sınıfın move member'larını delete etmiş.
Ama copy member'ları var.
Peki örneğin böyle bir senaryoda ne olacak?
Copy çalışmayacak.
Move delete edildiği için delete edilmiş fonksiyona yapılan çağrı sentaks hatası oluşturacak.
Ama move member'ları delete etmek yerine bildirmeseydi şimdi taşıma gereken yerde taşıma nereye düşecekti?
İşte orada fallback terimini kullandım ya kopyalamaya fallback olacaktı.
Arkadaşlar bugünkü ve bu haftaki derslerimiz de burada sona eriyor.
Derse katıldığınız için çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Bir dahaki hafta görüşmek üzere.
Herkese iyi çalışmalar veriyorum.
Hoşçakalın sevgili arkadaşlar.
Altyazı M.K.